this is jocko podcast number 322 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
find a new mission
that right there is some advice that i
have
given a bunch of guys a bunch of
veterans over the last
decade because when you leave the
military
that mission that you've been on
this honorable mission
all of a sudden overnight
it's gone
and
that's gonna leave a hole
and the longer you serve
the bigger that hole is going to be
and
for some of us if the only thing you
ever really wanted to do was serve and
execute that mission
it
can be a rough transition
especially after you spend
20 plus years
[Music]
with the opportunity to do
what you always wanted to do
to wear the cloth of the nation to take
the fight to the enemy
and it's an honor to have had the
opportunity to do that
to work with a bunch of other people
that are also dedicated to one thing in
life and that is executing the mission
so once that's gone
like i said it can be a rough transition
and you have to find a new mission and
some veterans go into business
some of them focus on their family some
of them start non-profits
[Music]
those are the positive things you can do
some serving other ways
and some just seem to keep going and
keep getting after it
and keep moving forward with new
missions
and we're lucky enough to have
people like that in our country
and
i know one in particular that served
in special forces is green beret fought
in afghanistan and iraq
served as a contractor
supporting the state department
supporting the cia
spent almost nine years
all told in iraq afghanistan and syria
and in a bunch of places all over the
world as well
but
that wasn't enough
needed more missions
this guy is also a businessman
owned crossfit gym a giant crossfit gym
has a firearms range and a tactical
training company
and he's competed in crossfit and
weightlifting and ironman and ultra
running and he's coached athletes from
crossfit and strongman and triathlons
and on top of all that
in december of 2021 just a few months
ago
he volunteered once again
with a new mission to represent the
people of north carolina
by running as an elected elected member
of congress
this man's name is tony cowden
and it's an honor to have him here with
us tonight to share some of his
experiences and the lessons that he's
learned along the way tony thanks for
coming by thanks for having me what's up
with that bio
take it take it easy man
uh you know people always say
like hey man i know you're busy you know
yeah i'm busy i'm always busy i don't
take naps i freaking
i'm busy you know i got stuff to do and
when i don't have things to do i find
things to do you know the old thing like
if you ain't got anything to do clean
something
um i'm probably not that good at that if
you ever see any of my guns that's not
what i'm known for um
but yeah man one thing after another and
you hit it on that intro how many
how many of our
brothers in arms got out and that hole
consumed them
you know they didn't find purpose they
everybody wants to know
well why is suicide so bad you know most
veterans and across the united states in
general
purpose
people with purpose don't commit suicide
you know
and when guys get out of the military
like you said especially
after feeling used and abused in the
20-some years war now
where
even the war itself guys started
questioning the purpose
what was the purpose and at this point
we certainly don't know
but uh yeah man without purpose
you know guys start drinking it's a
depressant it's a it's poison you know
they don't stop training because
you know like me i've always liked to
train by myself you know i've only had
one training partner in my entire life
it's my girlfriend melissa
yeah she's the only dude i know that can
keep up no i'm kidding i actually try to
keep up with her
but i was just that guy that went to the
gym by myself it was my time i went to
run by myself i went rough by myself i
swam by myself either that's safe or
anything but whatever
um
and but you know those guys on the teams
that go to the gym with their buddies
you know they got their little click
little two and three man team that goes
to the gym
you know when those guys get out of the
service they stop working out you know
they lose their physical fitness they
drink maybe they got hurt and the va put
them on an opioid you know the story you
know and
they don't have purpose
and uh it breaks my heart
um so many americans not just veterans
right because
you know
throughout the gym and everything like
that that grew so many
civilian friends or whatever and i don't
use that term you know negatively in any
way uh some of my best friends are
regular people some of my best friends
are civilians our best friends are
regular people right and a lot of times
you know the deal we see we would use
that terminology like
when on the teams and stuff like regular
people like it was we kind of looked at
him out of the corner of eye not down
adam but you know we recognized it you
know
we got this little team and we really
think we're the most awesome ever you
know like the old joke you know you want
to know who the best is in special
forces or special operations ask any
unit they'll tell you right ask a seal
seals are the best ask the ranger
they're the best you know all with very
different missions
but yeah man um americans in general
especially after this whole pandemic
they're wild no people are losing that
that purpose and we're losing that pride
in our nation and you know now with all
the containment and the mass and the
mandates and stuff man suicide mental
health is
i mean it's it's scary
you know that's of despair it's been a
nightmare um
let's get into all that in a little bit
but let's start off just to get to know
you a little bit uh let's start at the
beginning
um
uh a little white trash redneck kid uh
from very royal north carolina um
you know and i that's definitely in
terms of endearment my my dad 82nd
airborne guy oh yeah dude um
won a weekend leave from fayetteville
fort bragg in wilmington met my mom
azalea festival weekend that's a big
thing in wilmington the festival
and um
apparently he was head over heels in
love with my mom right and uh you know
freaking they got married he got out of
the army moved back to where he was from
up in indiana she was from pamlico
county north carolina we always use we
have to use the county as a marker
because there's no town in pimlico
county that anyone would even have heard
of unless you actually lived or visited
there often right so nearest towns like
new bern so it's very rural one of the
biggest counties in north carolina
smallest populations
so anyway they went up to indiana and um
are you born yet at this point not yet
um
my older sister is about to be on her
way
and he took a job with one of the
companies who made parts for general
motors right all that area up there
indianapolis detroit everything that's
all general motors ford so on and so
forth
and uh
after three or four years of being up
there
he did a couple other things he got like
his pilot's license and
um
which apparently
back then you didn't actually have to
have
there were dudes flying airplanes were
just flying airplanes while drinking
liquor and stuff the stories that they
used to tell us right they were small
and you find these little super cubs and
piper cubs around and you know he was
coming out shooting you know doing
aerial you know shooting foxes and stuff
i'm like these crazy suckers were doing
aerial sniper [__] with freaking hunting
rifles and shotguns you know he's like
yeah you know those little super cubs
will fly so slow that you could shoot
you know coyotes and foxes and deal with
a shotgun and i'm like oh wow drinking
he's like
you know i was like man you guys were
nuts
um so i joke that you know when we're
all out you know thinking we're cool
shooting out of a helicopter yeah a
bunch of redneck dude's been doing it
for a long time
um but uh yeah so you know man some
affirmative action policies
uh
my dad got pushed over for some
promotions over those years and like he
should have been in a supervisory role
he was like you know people are getting
promoted that have less time or less
qualification got disgruntled with the
whole
manufacturing world we can call it
corporate per se manufacturing you know
and it's like all right well they moved
back down to carolina where my mother
was from
and he took a job with a seafood company
that's right on the pamlico sound so
docks food seafood would come off the
boats there they'd package process it
sent it to the restaurants a few years
later he bought that company
so at this point my older sister was
born
i was born in this little time frame
there and
you know by like so i was born in 76 so
by 82 the business is doing good you
know so
and i'm old enough to be aware of it and
you know i've got an older sister and a
younger sister so when my dad needed
help
guess guess who the laborer was you know
so
you know but i'll tell you you know my
dad my dad wasn't like you know by
today's parenting standards my dad was a
horrible father
right like he wasn't that nice to me um
he wasn't the lovey-dovey you know hugs
and kisses type but he wasn't abusive
either right like you know i'd get a
spanking if i deserved it and i looking
back i probably deserved every one plus
a few i didn't get
but uh you know he was he wasn't a very
good teacher
right he was the type of guy like by
today's standards like he was just he
did it all wrong
but you know
my older sister is a
a world renowned pediatric
endocrinologist right like if you google
her name
you know pretty amazing woman out of one
of the most role
underfunded school systems in america
my younger sister is a successful
social worker in raleigh she helps a lot
of people who does some amazing things
of the three of us she's the most left
um i don't know that she would even vote
for me
my older sister she's in the moderate my
older sister's that
you know that that mother in america
that was in the middle
and kind of got pushed into the left
over the last you know four or five
years
um but she's she's that person i talk
about we need to win them back
you know she's conservative she was
raised conservative hell she grew up
shooting hunting and everything i did
but anyway my um my dad was that guy
that was like hey look
you need to do this and you need to do
this and you better have this done
before i get home i feel like dad i
don't know how to do that stuff
figure it out
and at the time i thought he was just an
[__]
you know i just thought he wouldn't
didn't like me i don't know and that's
mean to me blah blah whatever actually i
probably wasn't even aware it's just how
it was
because most of the fathers in my
neighborhood were very similar
and i grew up in one of the
neighborhoods like if you were caught
misbehaving down the street
you might get a spanking from the
neighbor right like they were all family
we all went to church together
you know and um and then you get another
one when dad got home but you know
looking back man he taught me so much he
taught me to figure it out and come to
find out that was the whole point he
didn't care if i completed it you know
at a hundred percent you know
awesomeness or whatever you know he just
wanted me to try and it's not like these
days man someone gives you a task like
i'll just youtube it you know it's right
here in here i'll just watch a video
step by step it'll be easy
you know and uh we didn't have that
growing up right
so
if you just had an extension cord and a
freaking skill saw right good luck
you know the fact that i still have all
my fingers and toes because he let me
handle tools that
i so
my employees slash interns at the range
with the company
and i
i they have like training programs you
have to go through they can't just pick
up one of my chainsaws right you can
chop your leg off with a chainsaw like
that circular saws right
my dad was like yeah man just get it
done
um
welding
i learned it well because if i broke
something i better have it fixed before
he got home it looked like a big pile of
chewed bubble gum but you know as long
as it would hold together
yeah
so that was kind of my childhood man and
it was so many lessons learned i watched
my dad build this business uh from
nothing to you know took us to
comfortable i wouldn't say upper middle
class but you know
slightly above average middle class you
know especially for rural north carolina
cost of living is not huge
and um
he at boston property developed a piece
of property
into a subdivision on the water down
there one of the one of the really first
subdivisions uh
in that era in pamlico county when there
was a lot of resistance for change right
people don't we don't want them yankees
coming down here buying up our you know
riverfront property right
and so he got a lot of pushback and i
remember that was my probably my first
exposure you know he would come home
from a county commissioner's meeting and
these are all people we know right
there's thousand five hundred people in
in pamlico county and has been for like
80 years right like the population
doesn't change because the exact same
amount of people that move there or are
born there die or leave
yeah
so yeah man um
it was really cool that's when i learned
to run like large machinery at 12 13
years old my dad had me running a d6
bulldozer
like what we were putting the culverts
in for the road right we built the roads
in this place you're laying layers and
layers of gravel so you bought a d3 a d6
an excavator a backhoe all this stuff i
can't even reach the pedals on these
pieces of equipment i'm out there
running them
without a lot of instruction you know or
any instruction just go yeah and i'll
never forget you know putting the big
concrete tiles into the the the ditches
for the the road
i'm on the backhoe steering these things
in and he's in that ditch
talking thousand pound concrete tiles if
i make a mistake i would have killed him
oh yeah
looking back
i would have never trusted me i wouldn't
have gotten that ditch but he did
and i was like wow you know either a my
dad was a complete psychopath right um
which you know
he's one of those guys like mission man
we will get it done
i
being in the rain in the military not a
big deal because my dad was like it
would there was that local little
restaurant in town where everybody ate
breakfast all the men you know
and uh it'd be raining and they're like
all right we gotta go and they're like
oh working in the rain today is like i
don't get to choose the weather
that was his attitude man he was just a
tough mofo man just hard
hours upon hours of work you know and
i like to say i'm a decent balance
between him and my mother who was
you know the the more gentle the
i mean she was a she wasn't a puss by
any means right like she didn't put up
with none of my bs i she i probably got
more spankings from her than i ever did
him right you know but like you know
little pops on the on the ass or
whatever
you got more quality from the old man
but more quantity from that you know um
and some people say that you know i was
i was mama's baby boy right i was the
only boy that was different and uh you
know
my older sister man she's like she's
like a t-1000 she's the first version of
the terminator dude she is like when
people meet her they're like whoa dude i
thought you were intense no my older
sister's a machine
i i say there's probably like
five or six people on this planet i'm
i'm afraid of she's one of them you know
what i mean like there's a handful of
guys
we're all
you know
pretty tough dudes right you know can
hold our own and all that kind of stuff
but there's all of us have that handful
of guys that you're like
yeah that guy's kind of scary one of
those guys for me is my older sister
and i'm not kidding right like uh
she's just oh man she is what she is and
uh successful because of it but yeah man
you know watching my dad build those
businesses develop that piece of
property really set that foundation
and um
you know since i was involved in so much
of it because he didn't have labor you
know he didn't have help so i had to be
there you know i didn't get to play
sports in school like i wanted to
because he needed help
and looking back in a lot of ways those
lessons just continue to carry over
whether you know like heck when we were
in afghanistan or right before we were
going into afghanistan we were at the
fob
you need equipment moved around yeah i
knew how to run forklifts how do you
think we moved pilots around in that
seafood house
uh forklifts you know even that big
crazy machine that grabs the conexes
i went and jacked one of those from the
air force one time we just went to
moving around the entire lot you know
the entire all the contacts is you know
like hey go get that and bring it over
here next to our tent so we can pack out
get ready to infill
well i could do all of that when we got
into afghanistan you know i i knew how
to the the little local tractor that the
fella had you know we needed it to
move some stuff around with time i was
like yeah you know i can run that so
that foundation was huge
but more than any of the actual stuff
that i did or learned what he taught me
was that i can do anything
if you put your mind to it
it's just like selection
i don't remember selection being that
difficult
you know it was just like i had this
mission and it just had to be done i
mean i
you know he
he couldn't really afford all three of
us going to college you know
he was struggling a little bit
my mother died when i was 16. i was
after that i went i went to misbehaving
how'd your mother die cancer
yeah four year bout with it man and um
ultimately it wasn't really the cancer
that killed her it was a surgery
complications from a surgery so it's
kind of heartbreaking like
yeah she had been fighting it or
whatever really you know the struggle
back then was chemo which it still is
but you know you're talking in the early
90s man freaking chemo was rough and um
so i learned a lot from watching her
deal with it man she she would get up
and walk and exercise and work in the
yard and mow the yard you know
while
having to stop and throw up from chemo
yeah so one of the toughest people i
ever grew up with was my mother
and
yeah so after she passed man you know
i started being that bad kid you know
and
you know smoking weed wound up doing a
little blow whatever freaking got in
trouble you know
um who'd you
get in trouble with like school yeah you
know school the law yeah i got arrested
man freaking um
luckily you know it was all just minor
dumb stuff right it's not like i was a
you know you know dealing anything or
stuff like that i wasn't
you know making money off of just
partying you know just doing dumb
redneck stuff you know like hunting club
roads you know you don't want to get on
the road you get a dwi but we can ride
around these hunting club dirt roads
redneck stuff man you know drinking beer
and
you know and
you know do all the dumb stuff we were
doing and that was when you were still
in high school yeah so yeah my senior in
high school
um you know just being bad and but i was
still making good enough grades
excuse me yeah i was you know just
you know the deal man just how like
everyone in software all pretty smart
dudes we can get b's without really
trying any course we go to you know
most of us are b students in every
course and of course there's always that
one nerd over there that gets honor
grass you know
yeah whatever make fun of that guy what
a nerd yeah i wasn't the nerd i was a
misbehaved kid
just being a
jackass and you didn't play any sports
because you were working too much well i
did play a little bit but like uh
with drew from you know the team and
senior year stuff like that just just
because yeah man he needed help
afterwards
and
um so yeah man so you know also our man
we were the smallest uh school system
and right next door to us is like wes
craven you know this this that's a
school that's producing
you know pro football players you know
d.h conley over in greenville ecu the
big schools man and we're like uh
they're like we'll let pamela go play us
and they would just destroy us you know
they had like
defense and offense and special teams we
had a football team yeah you didn't
leave the field man there was times we
went to football games we didn't have
enough dudes you know we'll play
and you know so after you know a couple
years of that man i wasn't even really
interested you know it's like what's the
point i mean
you know the average dude on our team
you know we had that one 220 pound guy
where you go to west craven their entire
lineup's 200 plus pounds it's like we
would just they would mop the floor with
us so i lost interest in that and just
started working more and partying more
and uh yeah man so good enough grades to
get into nc state i look back and i'm
like i still don't know how they let me
in um you know not good enough grades
getting kind of scholarship
so
you might after the second year my
younger sister is only a year behind me
my older sister is four years ahead of
me
she's entering medical school where'd
she go to school she went to medical
school ecu where'd you go to undergrad
at unc chapel hill
yeah
so you know um
dad's paying out of pocket plus he's
still very much you know dealing with
the death of my mom and he he had he had
a really hard time man freaking you know
um i watched him lose a lot of weight
you know he didn't talk to people he
kept working you know and he worked more
which was already darn impossible and
you know being a young dumb punk kid i
couldn't recognize it because i'm
selfish like kids are
and
looking back i was like man i could have
been a better kid i could have been a
better son to him but i mean we were
kids we were young and
looking looking back man my mom taught
me the number one best lesson in my
entire life
and that is
everyone you know is going to die
right so as we entered that war i had
already
lost and i tried to use that terminology
one of the people that was closest to me
in my life
and
so that set me up for being able to deal
with how many of our brothers got killed
close friends and so on and so forth you
know our partner forces you know
i don't think guys always realize how
tight we get with those partner forces
you know i got some of my best friends
on this planet are
you know
muslims
that people don't always understand that
you know my especially in iraq where i
worked with the kurds for years the same
team of dudes for
seven eight years
and um so anyway her passing taught me
to appreciate why you have them
and that's why i don't use that
terminology
you lost them i didn't lose my mother i
can go
show you right now where she rests i
know exactly where she's at
so i didn't lose them it was a gain
right if someone in your life is so
tight with you that when they die it
breaks your heart right
you didn't lose anything you gained
something in life
because if if when we
understand that everyone we know and
love
they're gonna die
when you start thinking like that you
start appreciating them every day
you know
um so i can say man my mom taught me the
best lesson that i've ever had and it
set me up for success in the war
and don't get me wrong it doesn't mean
like i'm somehow callous or
you know uh immune to feeling sad and
upset you know there's still those
anniversaries there's just thoughts you
know there's memories that pop back up
to make us all upset you know and tear
up and
you know and so on and so forth but
yeah man freaking without her death i
don't know that now today i would be as
healthy mentally as i am
you know it just laid that foundation
yeah
you know and i tell people that all the
time and i have throughout you know once
i realized that
and i'll tell you
really probably number one thing that
really
woke me up 2013 in april 2013 my best
friend was gay i had a guy named ben
bittner
ben was better than everyone else he was
that cocky little
little uh that guy you know who
everything he did
you know he was just better than
everybody else he wasn't huge or jacked
but he was strong and fast and
uh so anyway man i got that phone call
and me and melissa hadn't been dating
very long we were driving up 5 40. it
was kind of early on a sunday morning
and i got a phone call i was like who's
this you know hey bro ben benner okay
holy [__] dude
pulled off the side of the road and
threw up because the one dude i thought
that was truly immortal right just got
suckered by the enemy an abated ambush
right
and
it had not been it was i mean shoot
that's 13 man we're 12 years into the
war and already got plenty of memorial
braces you know but for something about
when ben died it was like holy crap
we're not immortal you know i'd been
injured blown up you know how it is
as a young little trooper sometimes
right those close calls
they make you more arrogant and cocky
right
you know you start thinking that you can
get away with more and more and that's
probably where i was in 13
when i got born in 2009 like after my
recovery i went back meaner more
aggressive
you know
probably taking risks that i shouldn't
have you know looking back taking risks
with my teams and my my partner forces
lives just because i was
emotionally
wanting some retribution you know they
had killed some of my teammates and and
damn near killed me and
then ben died i was like holy [__] but
uh like i said without my mom's death i
don't know that i would have dealt with
any of it very well so yeah man um
nc state uh i like to say that i was
enrolled at nc state
so your participation level was low
well you know there's pelican county and
there's like you know uh my graduating
class is like 104 people so let's say
there was you know 55 60 girls in that
class right and then i get the nc state
there's girls everywhere
they were everywhere i was like holy
crap man there's like thousands of them
and uh
yes i was distracted to say the least
and um
you know i quickly found out that
classrooms where you have to be quiet
and pay attention to a professor and
it's not the best place to talk to these
girls so why would i waste my time going
to those classes
and uh so anyway freaking partying
wasting money you know that that we
didn't have my sister's in med school
now my younger sister's
going to school she went it was going
down at unc wilmington and um you know
it was clear you know that i was wasting
money i didn't have it my dad didn't
have it so withdrew
i joined the army you know
um was your first was that your first
time thinking about joining the army
absolutely not i didn't want to go to
college right and you know our
generation we have to blame our parents
for everything so my dad let me watch
rambo first blood when i was 9 or 10
years old done
those green berets they're real badasses
you know it says it right in that movie
and you know so from there on you're
like let's face it right like some guys
watch you know uh something that's got
seals in it and they're like oh yeah or
some guys will watch you know uh the
recon movie with clint eastwood you know
and your impression at a young point
well mine was rambo first blood and
freaking that
you know running around above the snow
line
rats in the caves i was like yeah i was
already playing in the woods all the
time anyway and i love to hunt no it
just man so from there on out yeah i
just want one of those funny green hats
which looking back i'm like damn that
hat sucks
it's made out of wool it's hot as hell
right like you want me to wear this wool
hat in fayetteville you know and 100
plus degrees in the summertime the
samuels in north carolina right like
this hat's dumb there's no bill it
doesn't keep the sun out of your face
there's not like a boonie cat
no ballistic protection why do we even
wear this dumb hat right like
anyway um but yeah that's what i wanted
and i i it didn't help i met a fellow
named jason mckenzie
at nc state and he was going green to
gold
and uh he started telling me was he a
former greenbrier yeah he was a gb at
the time and um he was getting his
commission and he went on to get his
commission go back to the 18 alpha
course and he went over to the unit
freaking stud he was a stud real smart
dude
still is
and um yeah man i was like started
talking to him he's like hey look bro i
get in college sucks
let me tell you about this really cool
secret it's card that's called the
national guard special forces groups and
i was like what how's that even possible
right how can you have a reserve special
operations we'll come to find out
most all of us have that and uh he's
like it is the coolest most least known
way to get into special forces i'm like
what do you mean you know where do i
sign up
and he's like yeah man so basically you
go in and it's just like an active duty
group i mean they just you know less
[__] and that's really what it
almost comes down to is like the guard
gets on orders it's not like they're
doing you know one week in a month two
weeks a year type of thing you know
they're doing weeks of training at a
time
if when they deploy it's
you know months of work up pmt just like
the group they have to check all the
same boxes just in a lot less time
and i'm like okay yeah he's like so how
does it work he's like well you know
he's got me all hooked up with 19th
group the guy's up in west virginia
um i had to get a waiver for my missed
behaviors and arrests right
what year is this so this is uh 97.
and was it hard getting waivers
it wasn't were you a minor when you got
arrested
no uh yes yes and no
both okay
i had just turned 18. um
with one of the arrests i was still a
senior in high school
and uh but everything else was before
that
uh
nah man freaking
so i go and talk to these guys and
colonel hoyer was the battalion
commander for a second battalion of 19
special forces group and he moved on to
become like the the general the tag of
west virginia really smart man really
smart guy
and um not a not a very imposing figure
um
you know
just an average looking guy a guy could
throw a suit on and disappear you know
not not the jack tattoo guys of course
tattoos on the sleeves and all that
weren't quite popular at a time and i
remember walking in and thinking
this is a special forces colonel i was
expecting you know like john the colonel
the colonel connor chapman from rambo
right supposed to scare the [__] out of
me very unassuming which come to find
out later yeah those are the dudes that
are really the scary guys anyway well
anyway conor hoyer was like um yeah so
you need a waiver
you gonna do this anymore
and i'm like no sir done with that that
was you know three years ago i'm
good
okay boom that easy you know and and had
he
in his assessment of me for whatever
reason you know um because i know him to
have turned down similar cases but man
it was there was no interview nothing he
just took me on a very first impression
basis and i was just a dumb kid i didn't
know i'm like scared to death all these
dbs you know i'm like you know i'm
trying to join this very exclusive club
and
i don't know what to say i don't know
how to act
so nothing i would have done would have
been right anyway
but uh yeah he gave me the waivers
i withdrew from school on a tuesday
morning uh you know raleigh to pimlico
county to the house is about two hours i
went home my dad was at home i was like
yeah changed into some pts and went for
a run
sure enough met him on the road he like
hits the brakes he's like what up are
you doing why are you home you're
supposed to be in college boy what's
wrong with you
and you know he knew at this point like
oh something's up right like just saying
right you know great he's probably in
trouble again that was probably his
first impression i'm like i'll run to
the house out i'll meet you there
he probably would have pulled over to
the side of the road and got out and we
would have had that discussion on the
side of the road but my stepmother he
luck good lord man luckily for my dad
man he met an amazing woman after my mom
died and who became one of my very best
friends
sad story she died of cancer too
yeah my dad man god bless his heart
so my stepmom's with him and i remember
she kind of like patted him on the
shoulder and was like let him come home
and talk to us you know because my dad
wasn't a little dude either right like
he's you know
about my size now right i was always
smaller than him until i finally started
lifting some weights i was actually way
more of a runner dude early on i was
like buck 70. you know i could run
i had no real weight on me you know but
he was like 2 2 10. you know he's
yeah the few times we did scuff it up a
little bit yeah he just wiped me off
right i just covered up
and uh you know like i said anyway man
freaking uh yeah so
i go to the house and i tell him he's
just shaking his head but it's like he
understood
you know he understood he knew i mean of
course i'm insane he knew me
i'm his he joined the 82nd airborne for
the same reason i wanted to go
so yeah man um a few weeks later i was
in basic training that quick huh yeah
yeah it was like
two and a half months from the time i
signed up i was already in basic
training because back then you know late
90s
recruitment was at a pretty low there
the clinton administration they had
routed the military and cut so much
funding but
trying to get guys to sign up for combat
arms you know the recruiter would be
like heck yeah sign him right up come on
in here you know
so yeah i did that um how was boot camp
i was in such good shape that it was
like easy i think i got in worse shape
when i got there i was already getting
like a 340 on the army's pt test
right and a lot of it was you know i
could max a push-up in sit-ups but my
run time was like i was running like
11 flat two miles you know just a little
rough runner dude right
and uh and skinny god bless my heart i
look back at some of them pictures man
i'm like wow
wow boy you needed to eat
did you you never ran like competitively
no in high school or anything no no i
didn't start running i joined the rotc
at nc state because you know okay well
maybe i want to join the army but you
know maybe i'll be an officer
yeah you know that didn't really play
out that way
and but that was the first time i
started doing pt and running and i think
like my first pt test i must have run
like a 15 minute two mile but like my
second one was sub 12.
yeah so apparently had some decent
pre-disposition genetic predisposition
to running and your uh the shock of boot
camp was no factor because you were just
stoked to be there right yeah and and
you know at this point now i'm
20 so i'm one of the oldest kids in
basic training and i'm even back then
i'm looking around doing looking like
dude these are a bunch of [__] where
do these
kids come from right like clearly they
didn't work like you know my dad you
know
in my head i think every american boy is
like me you know and now there's these
city kids and
whatever man yeah but
basically it wasn't hard i remember i
got like you know
top pt and you know was quickly made
like the stupid platoon sergeant or
whatever and i was like great you know
and you know there was a little click
you know because i did the basic and ait
back to back so it was like 14 weeks so
you same drill sergeants all the way
through by the end me and these couple
other boys are a little bit older a
little bit
more mature you know we were running
things we had our own little mafia going
you know we had
when they let us clean the drill
sergeant's uh
uh office
we took the key snook off post made a
coffee a copy of it so now we had a
drill sergeant's
office key which had all our personal
bags in the
right like so we would go in there and
listen to the walkmans and cds and you
know like hide out
and it was funny because the drill
starters had no idea we were doing it
much less that we were leaving post you
know you can't leave post in basic
training there's no cell phone like
nowadays they can make phone calls and
be on the internet none of that you're
on lockdown right
we were sticking off post and like
because we had access to the civilian
clothes
he was thinking i'll post going and
buying beer and it's stashing it in the
drill sergeant's office in the personal
right and we go in there at night and
house a few beers you know buy some
liquor
no clue so i always say like i was
already running an underground auxiliary
when i was in basic training like sf was
just you know
where i was you guys
but yeah man i got out of there and um
freaking
immediately went to uh the little
progression course or whatever pldc
where you had to go from
uh you know to get your promotion to e4
or whatever
and
it was like a couple days before i
finished that little three week course
so you're already in e4 after like a few
months uh no i'm still in e3 i finished
because i did have a little bit of
college i was finished basic as an e3
and uh so now i'm in this little pldc
course so i can get promoted to e4 and
like hey
you ready to go to selection i'm like i
guess huh
when they're like
in two weeks man i haven't won a
rucksack
right and that's all our selection is is
carrying a rucksack for 28 days
i'm like
yeah okay okay because i'm like i'm not
going to say no i'm not turning down a
slot at sfas
looking back i could have been like hey
i really could stand another month of
training and they'd be like okay
whatever and put me in the next course i
didn't know it like that i thought just
an opportunity at selection must have
been a godsend you can't say no
so i had a whopping two weeks to train
for selection
it went straight there you know and even
then i look back and i'm like it wasn't
really that hard but it wasn't hard
because quitting wasn't an option right
i couldn't have withdrawn from college
all to go to special forces
and then fail
right
that wouldn't have been a thing i could
not have sold that to family members my
dad right myself
it couldn't happen how many people get
how many people make it through the so
that first selection what is it 28 days
you said back then it was 28 days right
it's changed a lot over the years um i
think right now it's 21 days of actual
course so maybe 26 days got in the admin
and all that so it was 28 back then
exactly four weeks
um
yeah there was
250 or so dudes in my class 52 finished
and
40 or 41 were selected
and i think a lot of folks don't know
that right you can finish that course
and not get picked up
you know 28 day non-select
yeah that's gotta hurt it's gotta hurt
and uh so yeah i got picked up and most
of those people are quitters or they're
performance drops or medical drops you
know they hurt their knees
yeah you know the the number one
attrition rate is voluntary withdrawals
yeah you know that's probably 95 and
then injury and you know it's funny i've
seen some dudes and i'm sure the same at
buds and everywhere else you see those
guys that like they've got stress
fractures broken ankle broken toes
you know torn patellar tendons and they
finish
you know
i was just young and stupid man freaking
i didn't i'm so lucky
i don't get blisters on my feet i never
have i got some of my first blisters
ever last year hunting in the mountains
of idaho
because i bought a pair of boots and
didn't really break them in i you know
warm around in north carolina working
around the house and then i throw a
backpack on and go hiking in the
mountains of uh idaho
and i call it hiking it was armed hiking
because we didn't kill anything
yeah it's not really hunting if you
don't well you know it's just armed
height really well armed hiking uh good
training i guess you could talk it up as
but yeah i had never even gotten a
blister like you know
um so i was lucky when it comes to that
because that's a big thing in our
selection it's like just dude's feet get
turned to hamburger
what do you how are you going to erupt
march if you ain't got you know feet
i've seen some you know blisters that
start at the toes and get like the back
of the heel
like things that like you could lose a
leg at over you know the medics are like
whoa
you know they have horrible you know a
little medic station they had all those
pictures and you think it's just some
genetic thing you just don't get
blisters i just for whatever reason my
feet uh fit jungle boots
which is weird because it's not like
there
you know i just did
so yeah man that just worked out
finished election
it was funny because at the time
reg said to finish it was before the 18
or the sf baby program the 18th x-ray
it was before that
and but the guard had the back door oh
it was like the 18x because i didn't go
to any other unit
and um
[Music]
so it's graduation day i had to go to
the strength and to the board a couple
times because i was in e3 and they're
like
you can't you're not even supposed to be
here much less finnish like what though
they didn't know what to do with me
again
some dudes looked at it gave me a waiver
but it was funny because you know the
company commander company commander in
the training sf training he's not really
involved in anything he shows up he's an
admin guy for the most part the enlisted
boys run selection
so
come time you know he's handing out you
know his graduation not very formal it's
out at camp mccall you're just all dirty
and nasty and you're walking across this
little stage and he's handing out he's
like staff sergeant such and such
captain such and such
sergeant such and such you know hey
shaking hands and i get up there and he
goes private
he for at the first sergeant and the
whole class knows we don't wear rank and
stuff there but you know right after
four weeks everyone knows who the cherry
lieutenant is
and and you know there were some guys
there probably who were pissed that i
was there as an e you know an e3
but most of the guys were like wow this
dude's crushing it and he's a baby but i
wasn't a child you know i wasn't 18. you
know
so the average age in there like 24 or
something yeah very much so you know you
average eight you know
senior e4 promotables e5s and e6's made
up the bulk of the class
and most of the officers were you know
first lieutenant and captains and um so
it was kind of funny because the whole
class like laughed and clapped yeah you
know because the the captain or the
company commander and major was like
what the hell what
he like talks to the first sergeant this
art major and they're like
he's like really and i'm like standing
there on the stage like am i getting
ready to get booted
you know the commander gonna go nope
right here
and uh so anyway freaking he shakes my
hand and goes all right private first
class calden welcome to regiment
right on
so man it was kind of screwed up i i was
in a race in motocross
one week before i was supposed to report
to the q course
broke my femur a couple ribs in my arm
yeah man at a race that i shouldn't have
been racing
are you not allowed to erase it uh no it
wasn't like that you know how you know
that wasn't on the list of things you
can't do you know like you're not
supposed to skydive
no one never thought these knuckleheads
are out there like
don't go ride rodeo it's on the list of
things that you're not supposed to do
while you know in the queue course well
i wasn't in the queue course yet but
motocross wasn't on the list
until i broke my femur they added
motorcycles to the list because of me
so
yeah man i um
i missed my q course day and i was
supposed to go to the delta course i
wanted to be a medic oddly enough my
plan was to go be a medic and either go
to pa school or medical school i wanted
to be like my terminator sister i was
the one that i probably want to be a
doctor more than she did
and but i was always in the you know i
wanted to be like the you know the er
doc i want to be the trauma guy so 18
delta just made sense
well eight months later i'm still
limping you know they put a rod in my
leg and all that um you know i got my
run times back down pretty good but man
it hurt it just hurt because i just
destroyed this leg man it was like
you know it was so atrophed afterwards
you know i could put my hands around my
quad it was just a bone in there and it
was it's nasty dude because when i
basically what happened was i over
jumped a a triple jump
the jump got wiped up and kicked the
bike
forward my buds were standing over there
so they could see
the drain plug on the bottom of the bike
the bike was pointed at the ground i was
still upright when it hit the ground the
front tire basically
trapped this leg and then
catapulted me just threw me up in the
air so when you said it's not a race you
should have been and it's like too
advanced of a race no it was the exact
opposite it was like a local outlaw race
not an ama sanction
it was just a fun race but there's no
fun races because you still gotta win
right
and and i was battling for first and a
funny thing was
i was racing the 250 class and the 125
class um at that time so i had already
erased those two and then there was this
the unlimited class where
it didn't matter you could erase
anything you wanted in it
and so i was racing six motors that
night six different races that afternoon
night
it was a six photo i was exhausted
and folks don't realize man like i'm in
phenomenal shape at this time right and
motocross is still one of the most
physically demanding things i've ever
done
and you know because you just don't
realize that you're you're strapped to a
230 40 pound piece of equipment that has
45 horsepower you know with the right
you know they're you're trying to
control that thing you know it's not
like you're just relaxing on it you're
standing up you're clenching it you know
between your legs all that and
anyway yeah man um
[Music]
so now my career is like okay now what
so
through advisement they're like hey look
you lost all this time
let me sign you up for the charlie
course the engineer demo of course i'm
like all right at this point i just want
to get in the course
you know i've been basically doing
nothing for eight months except for
rehab
and uh so okay cool
so i did the trolley course it was kind
of funny man in the charlie course
because i'm from north carolina so i
know people
at uncw which is a you know wilmington
is a college town with a beach problem
right
uh
nc state ecu party i have friends
everywhere so i was like the tour guide
on the weekend right like yeah i know
people at this school let's go to this
party all that kind of stuff so we're
having a good time that's where i met
that fellow ben bittner um our little
clique man a bunch of little crazy dudes
and um you know
borderline you know we were misbehaving
in the queue course you know because it
wasn't that hard you know especially in
the mos phase it wasn't very hard so we
were partying and
blah blah
yeah did all that stuff language school
wasn't hard back then because no one
cared about language you really didn't
have to go to language school so i went
to language school but did not learn
french
and then of course it didn't really
matter because
it was like
eight years later before i ever went
anywhere that spoke french you know a
lot of french speakers in iraq and
afghanistan you know
but yeah man freaking uh
cool stuff i um
i got lucky though because if i had done
the medic course i would have missed the
invasion
i'd have been in language school or
serious school
during that time frame so because i did
the shorter charlie course i was already
done and on a team
and doing some pretty cool stuff
afghanistan kicks off and i got to go at
the beginning where were you when
september 11th went down so when i
started doing cool stuff um my warrant
he was the aso guy right the
source operations guy not the door
kicker guy even though he had done all
that he had just matured into
understanding that that's the that's the
hard part right the finish is the easy
part right how long does this take us to
execute a target you know
30 to 90 seconds typically right we're
on target
everyone's zip tied or
done we're done with the target now
we're doing sse it's quick
it's that
find fixed part aso stuff
right it's actually difficult it takes a
brain
and he was all about that and because i
was that skinny college kid
i didn't look like an sf guy
so he got me signed up on this uh
program
that
fifth group tenth group all the active
duty groups were participating it was
tenth group's year to run it
and it was the red cell against the n
triple c the nuclear command and control
so for the four months leading up to 9
i'm running around the nation
tracking
and
you know developing patterns of life
of this general
he's got a suitcase attached to him
he's like
number 12 in the chain of command of
running our country in the time of
nuclear war with russia
and i had no idea because it was very
cellular
right it was broken down into little
cells
which is ironic
right because now we're playing red
against the united states nuclear
command and control
for those six months i didn't interact i
did not see face to face it was all old
school cold war tradecraft dead drops
notes no text messages nothing the only
time i got text messages call is when i
actually called the handler
who was a chief out of 10th group and he
was running our cell
so we were in oklahoma nebraska
silos man right and this guy would go
from silo facility to silo facility with
these tractor trailers that
in descript three tractor trailers or so
um and that could change right and then
a security detail
that you know all plain clothes and
stuff right like you're driving down the
highway you would never notice this
convoy of course they didn't nut to buck
convoy either it was just these three
tractor trailer trucks
and uh and sometimes more than that
sometimes the convoy was much larger
when they had other pieces of equipment
that i had no idea what it was i only
cared about him
because the ultimate goal was when we
were supposed to execute
we were trying to
create
a four second hiccup in the united
states nuclear reaction to russia's
attack
four seconds that was what it was
that's all supposedly russia needed
four seconds man well come to find out
man it was a worldwide effort it wasn't
just my four goofballs and i knew there
was some others because other teammates
of mine were scattered around the
country
and i knew they were doing it i had no
idea where they're at because the last
time i saw him was a meeting in northern
virginia where we all came together they
briefed us and sent us on our way and it
was fun man i'm this new little punk kid
little sf dude man they were you know
unlimited budget freaking just swiping a
government credit card there was days i
had two different rental cars freaking
you know hotel
you know and it was an amazing thing
it was really cool because you know had
to get interim ts which back then a
little baby e6 i didn't have ts
clearances
so that that paved the way to getting my
my clearances set up and all that
um much younger than
i should have probably
um or at least was standard at the time
so yeah man on the morning of 9 11
i would crawled
through this drainage little culvert
freaking i went to walmart bought some
leafy gucci flies from walmart and then
freaking got my little crappy walmart
ghillie suit and i crawled like for four
hours to get within taking a picture of
this general that was going to be the
shot
and like i said i mean you got teams
around the world taking pictures of
different types of planes and tell
numbers and oh this plane took off in
interlude turkey and then it landed in
alaska
like they flew across the north pole
yeah i mean these are these are some
crazy assets right
well
yeah man so
i get a text
and it's like abort
move to such and such
and i'm like i'm not compromised
i'm good
right now
was the text i got back aboard right now
and i'm watching his security detail
change
what's happening
and um as i'm crawling out man freaking
like the local sheriff's department
freaking starts pulling in dudes they've
got shotguns right local redneck dudes
some marines showed up i guess they were
like
freaking had been hovering this whole
time this marine detail that i was not
even aware of well luckily they weren't
aware of me either so now i'm calling
quickly
because it's clear something is going on
right because they've got mags in their
guns and i'm like what the [__] man
get out get my car freaking call hey
what's up yeah meet me at this motel
it's like you know side of the road dirt
motel one story old school you know
1950s built motel
and there's like 40 rental cars in this
motel parking lot i'm like what the
hell is going on we'll come to final
it's not my four-man cell
and there was redundancies upon
redundancies for all these cells at
every location around the world man and
none of us knew about each other
and a couple of them you like recognize
because this thing's been going on for
months and i'm like i saw you in
nebraska i saw you males females and
this is that's a that's a good point
because
that was the first time in my life i
realized how important females are for
you know reconnaissance surveillance
freaking like wow they do have a major
role that that changed a lot of my
career the way i saw women and how they
can be an asset right like
me and you yeah
right how do we walk around we're not
bleeding in anywhere all right we don't
even blend in an average u.s freaking
you know city much less throw on some a
man dress and try to walk around
jalalabad right no we're busted
but man these ladies you know they can
go and do especially when you recruit
the ones that can speak arabic and you
know can blend in right which we learned
that lesson but this was my first time
seeing females i was like holy crap
come to find out one of the people on my
team was a female i didn't know i'm just
dead dropping letters and notes so
anyway
as i walk in the hotel room man yeah
there's like 40 people in this little
hotel room it's not i mean just cramped
in sitting looking at a tv
of burning towers
yeah man i'm just sitting there going
okay what the [__]
we're under attack
and at this point you know it's early in
the morning no one even knows
pentagon hadn't been hit yet
and um so
it that happened while we were sitting
there we're just like whoa okay so we
pack up we actually went and linked up
with that
asset
and
provided a ring of security for them and
escorted them so we went from
playing red cell against them to helping
with their security cordon
we were unarmed so we pulled in outer
security and escorted him to a hard
location damn
yeah and then got on planes and flew
back to wherever we were supposed to
they were unit guys there were guys from
damn neck involved um everybody flew
back as fast as they could but planes
were grounded so they're sending c-17s
from wherever they could and picking us
up we drove 100 mile an hour all the way
to colorado springs you know the tenth
group
got all got on flights
wherever we could get them it was always
funny because you know like
the tier one guys you know the the
learjets were waiting for them we're
just waiting on like whatever we could
get like oh can i get on that crop
duster get a ride back to brag you know
but i always remember that was my first
impression of those guys was like how
come they get learjet you know oh
they're they're important
we're the scrubs
but um yeah man so that's how it all got
started you know um
i had a slot to go to mff and you know
national guard
young sf dude to get a slot in free fall
was a big deal back then you know
because back then we didn't all sf
didn't all go to freefall
and
so that chief was like well i mean your
orders are good for another year you're
detailed and assigned to us and what do
you want to do
i was like what do you mean
well you can go to free fall or you can
come with us i'm like
i'm with you let's go a couple weeks
later man we were in afghanistan
you know young dumb kid what'd that look
like so that what i mean what kind of
what would they do say all right here's
what we're doing mm-hmm
yeah a lot of people figure it out every
dad used to say to you yeah yeah i mean
it was like hey um you know call your
family members we're going to isolation
monday
we're doing what what's that what's
isolation like this is how like i only
isolation i knew about was that robin
sage i didn't completely understand
right and honestly most of the guys
didn't either it was like just because i
was new
none of the force had been to war either
there was still only a handful of guys
in sf because only a handful of fifth
group dudes got to play in the gulf war
a handful of guys from mogadishu you
know
no combat experience yeah i was going to
say in your actual team there might have
been zero
the chief had stuff in south america in
the 80s
you know but all you know by with and
through advisement stuff um
but yeah man so we're like okay well
here we go
and um yeah man uh got to go and be in
tour borah you know so there's basically
a lot of
because it's funny for us like we all
know how it all played out but i mean
there's an entire generation of
americans
that were born either right at or after
9 11 who don't understand right there
was two parts of afghanistan there was
the taliban
right the horse soldiers and everybody
that came down from
the north and bagrun you know triple
nickel you know all that team did all
that and then there was tora bora
pardon me
and um you know al qaeda
so i got lucky enough to be involved in
all of that
my team settled in jalalabad
where'd you fly
how did you get in there uh hilo yeah so
you he loaded into jalal about did you
guys get up um we he loaded in south of
jalalabad north of turbo and then what
was your what'd you do
um well just supported mostly supported
the jtacs and cct guys dropping bombs
right and tried to mostly coordinate and
keep our you know there was two main
warlords in this region and one was
hazard ali and the other was saman
and zaman spoke english and was the
agency's pick to be that nangahara
warlord that nangahar leader
well zaman had lived in britain for 10
or 12 years he left afghanistan
hazard ali was mooji man he was he was a
a farmer right
you know a lot of folks don't realize
man you know afghanistan of the 14 most
opium producing countries in the world
afghanistan was number 14 when we
invaded
it's number one right now
that's a horrible result of this war
well hazar ali
who ultimately became the minister of
defense of afghanistan was a farmer
but also a freedom fighter moves against
the taliban the taliban very much
disallowed opium growth you know they
they were all about they you know that
was a sin so
you know we changed that by getting rid
of the taliban
all right everybody started growing
opium you know and wow what beautiful
fields those pink red flowers man
they're beautiful but
it's just death growing out of the
ground you know
so anyway yeah man um how long are you
on the ground for
uh
how long how much longer this is where
my first employment this is that
question is where my fairy tale of
initial entry into special horses begins
to end
so
fifth group wanted out as fast as they
could so january february they're
already like yeah we're going to the
horn when did you get there november
so november december january and fifth
group is already this group is like they
want out they want to get to the horn of
africa right there's still no talk of
iraq at this point right it's like oh
horn of africa we're going to somalia
everybody wanted that they're like oh
okay we're gonna go get some and return
that favor right that's ten year old
favor we owe those somalis
everybody wanted to get there well then
the clear the battle plans changed and
iraq became a thing
well
so 19th group and third group start
showing up so they're like hey look
we're just gonna you're gonna be
continuity you're gonna help this next
team rip in
right so
i got left
it wound up staying like another six
months man i was like oh no so that's
where that fairy tale everything
happened really cool kind of went oh
[__]
but it wasn't bad because i wound up uh
being on a team with a bunch of dudes
that were good friends of mine i
actually got to go be an lno for
a few weeks up in tashkent uzbekistan
so as a you know 24 25 year old young
little buck um my first experience in a
former soviet uh area it was nice nice
four weeks of partying i was supposed to
work at the embassy i think i went to
the embassy twice
i was the assistant
the lno
was this former
10th group dude who had retired got
called back in
and he had been working like the
miami-dade
um organized crime task force he was uh
he was his name i might say his name he
uh he had a very ukrainian name he was
from the ukraine he came to america when
he was like 12 so he spoke russian
ukrainian man he had all kinds of stuff
going on in ukraine or not ukraine uh
uzbekistan
and uh he was connected as the eleanor
up there if you needed something out of
his back saying he could get it
i mean the second night i was up there
the dude took me to a party at the uk or
ukraine uzbekistani's
president's daughter's house her mansion
this dude knew everybody he was the
quintessential sf guy right but he's
like almost 60 he's kind of overweight
he speaks russian and um he's he's
fluent
so
like four days after i get up there he's
like oh yeah i'm going to the states so
now i'm just up there the assistant oh
uh and i'm living in the sheraton which
that's russian for a sheraton hotel um
that's all i learned and uh
and so i just partied for like four
weeks and um you know basically my job
was to take you know my bud my becky
driver buddy and go pick up people from
the airport take them to the hotel and
then take them back to the airport so
they could fly into the fob you know and
uh so yeah man freaking pretty cool but
yeah so back to afghanistan and then
finally home and uh did you do any good
ops like what kind of missions were you
doing yeah we did a lot of cool stuff
you know of course you know dropping all
the bombs and and
um tour board was cool of course we
started and there was still a lot of you
know stuff out there you know we went
after some um
um
daggone chechens you know some of those
as they were you know because
were you guys already working with a
partner force yeah we started the
initial what became the commandos it was
called the mrf the murph mobile reaction
force there in jalalabad july bob wasn't
a base it was just a crappy airfield
every time we went to get a resupply we
had to clear the airfield
and clear the runway make sure they
didn't put anything on it you know the
mc130s would you know
squeak in the middle of the night drop
our junk off
and um so we started building what
became jalalabad's fob we built ranges
out there
and started training this uh hazrat
ali's guys
and that you know i was talking about
zaman and hazrat ali they they're the
reason
freaking uh ubl got away
they were supposed to be helping us deal
with al-qaeda and they turned on each
other right so zaman the cia's pick no
one liked him he had no real pull he was
nobody most of these kids had never
heard of him and ali who's been there
you know running this show
he's not having it
so yeah man they start fighting with
each other and you got like you know
half the teams over there with them and
some of the other teams and then half of
us are over here with zama or uh how's
all these guys and they're fighting each
other
and we're like wait wait wait wait we're
supposed to be killing those dudes
so it screwed the war up for about three
days
as we sorted that mess out and yeah man
that's when that's when he escaped
that's when he got how did you guys sort
that out
um ultimately the agency stepped in they
were running the show there right the
juliet teams and you know we were
basically supporting them um
and um we had two masters right we had
the fob in fifth groups colonel
mulholland and then of course we had the
the ground branch guys and they
they were running the show in tor boro
and um so
we uh
freaking sorted that mess out and
basically they told zamon like hey stand
down okay and once everything was
hashed out
settled back everybody went to jalabhad
zaman actually went back to the to
britain they exiled him that's what
hazrat ali told everybody that he acts
out him but really the agency was like
hey man you just need to leave yeah yeah
so it was a bad call it was you know a
one of those convenient things he spoke
english hazard i really didn't
bad call on our part on who we decided
we thought we could put in power
um we didn't really understand how much
influence has really really had over the
past two people well at least they had
the humility to recognize that and say
all right cool we screwed this up let's
get this guy out of here and move
forward you know it's interesting that
history repeats itself right like
talking to the sf guys in vietnam
they would have those
like guys shoot each other on base
between the the the hmongs and uh
whatever other groups like the regular
vietnamese they'd get in fights right
and shoot each other yeah
like well then they go on a mission with
these guys that's one of our biggest
problems right we for some reason as
americans we have this arrogance that we
think everyone's like us and likes the
things we like and
well
you know
we have this amazing experiment in
america this diversity that's never been
this way anywhere else on the planet
ever
so
we can
walk out on the street and go to
mcdonald's and see
20 different ethnicities freaking people
from all around the world
right at least their ancestors are and
in some cases they literally just came
from that
[Music]
well in other countries those people
will fight each other right they're like
from different villages and different
tribes and they don't like each other
and they're never going to we think we
can impose that
right like
americans can't grasp why the shia and
the sunni
absolutely hate each other and will
fight each other and the only time
they'll come together
is to fight someone else they hate more
us or israel you know
um
yeah you know americans and we're bad
about it you know we really think we can
imply uh or impose our way of doing
things
and it it you know the deal man you got
your colonel or whoever else at the fob
we're out there living with these boys
you know living with them they're our
team and we're trying to explain all the
dynamics of it and you've got some
colonel who's never done even like fidz
or jset much less run an unconventional
war with a partner force it was
frustrating you know because it to me
it's just simple you know it's like hey
just be nice to all these people so you
can stop treating them like crap and
realize that
that tribe and that tribe should not
ever be put in the same unit and given
loaded weapons they will shoot each
other
but
it's us you know it's just how we do
things and like you said it we just
repeat it time and time again yeah
sometimes i think it's
it it's
conceit or whatever arrogance that we
think well if we tell you guys to work
here they're going to work together and
sometimes i think it's just arrogance
people just don't realize like hey hey
these
these two people that you're talking to
right now they don't they're not going
to get along ever ever ever ever nothing
you can do yeah
unless for some reason
as well if there's someone that they hit
worse they'll go against that person but
who's that person's going to be an ally
for the next two days how much money are
we going to get out of this you know if
it like and you know that's funny i i've
i've always tried to tell folks there's
a huge difference between allies and
friends and allies are usually pretty
predictable because that means we have a
a very common
goal a common enemy a com we have a
commonality whereas friends a lot of
times friends are that's a loose
relationship based mostly on emotion
right
and you you see it all the time
who who hurts our feelings the most are
friends
our allies are predictable right when
you go into an alliance so like business
advice i've always given guys business
advice one of the lessons i learned was
don't start a business with a friend
if you have to have a partner and you
shouldn't take a partner but if you have
to have a partner get this endeavor
started
do not do it with a friend
i haven't listened to that advice like
all my businesses are with all my
friends
i hope you've had better luck than i
have good luck with it good man
it's hard you know when you got
especially we tend to like start
businesses with guys like us and we're
all so hard-headed and set in our ways
and all that you know and if there's not
some type of clear hierarchy and those
operations agreements and that stuff
that you can always go back to and be
like hey buddy this is what the company
says well in my case we didn't even have
like an operations agreement we just
started it and then it you know
luckily it didn't dissolve into where we
hated each other anything like that but
you know i
my dad always told me man it's like you
don't need a partner don't have one
you know and then sure enough he was
right
wow he was smart
but yeah man the career was awesome i uh
so so how so you end up going to so you
end up spending this first like what is
it you ended up nine months in
afghanistan with a little bit of time
seven and a half months seven and a half
months
and then what happens so went home and
uh and when you're in the national guard
are you you're in the national guard
yeah but i'm on active duty okay so it's
no different right no difference so you
know the guard guys would mobe and
d-mode and there'd be two months on the
you know if they let's say they deployed
for eight months and that was pretty
typical it was two months of mobe
and then two months of demo for a total
of a year
um deployment got it and so eight months
deployment two months on the front end
two months on the back end that became
the standard for sf uh national guard
well
mine was kind of like what do i do now
who do i belong to who am i working for
and um
so
i was lucky i
freaking
went and did some the counter drug
mission for the national guard it's
advisement to law enforcement so i did
that until state side
yeah and it's uh it's providing
surveillance training um
you know it's like it's kind of what
about possible
skirt well you know we're unarmed most
of the time you know sometimes
no we're really going to go out in the
middle of west virginia and surveil
these meth heads with 30 out six rifles
i'm probably going to carry my personal
firearm and deal with the ramifications
later
um
and i've had a couple times where meth
heads like
we were in snow
we actually didn't think he was home
he must have been sleeping it off you
know because meth heads would you know
they'd be up for days and then they'll
sleep for days and we thought this meth
trailer there was no you know they
weren't cooking or whatever and we're
sitting on the side of this mountain
it's snow we're wearing woodland
camouflage freaking we're messing about
we didn't build a high site some come up
we're not taking it seriously and i mean
we're like 250 meters from this dude's
uh it's like a cabin and a trailer up in
this holler in west virginia
dude he comes out and starts scanning
with his hunting rifle on a scope dang
and we're just sitting there trying to
like get behind you know trees
dude we're sticking out like sore thumbs
and we're not wearing over whites or
anything just dumb because like i said
we weren't taking it seriously you know
we've just been to afghanistan we're a
bunch of tough guys what's this dumb
redneck gonna do but lucky that redneck
didn't see us and shoot us right cause
let's face it redneck boys you know they
can shoot
it wouldn't been the first time he shot
something with that hunting rifle you
know and i was like oh good god i was
running a recon course one time this is
like before the war and i had this group
up in the mountains
and
they're they're like laid up in
hindsight right and i'm a land grader
right so i'm i'm out there but i'm
cammie'd up too because i'm all fired up
so i would like sneak around and so i'm
kind of sneaking up on them to kind of
observe what they're doing to make sure
that they're being squared away
and as i'm sitting there observing them
and i'm not that far away from them like
50 meters away
a guy
i hear like a dog right and i'm like oh
these guys are gonna get you know busted
this is gonna be cool i'm gonna watch
the whole thing
so a guy comes down he's got two
freaking german shepherds with them and
they look badass they look like freaking
wolves
and so the guys you know i'm watching
this whole thing play out and you know
you the guys pick up that they're coming
because they it was a squared away
little crew they they pick up a guy come
they like fade in they're they're
hunkered down
guy comes walking down this path there
wasn't even a road as a path
and he doesn't he's none the wiser
and all of a sudden the dogs bro the
dogs are like they stop they start
growling and all of a sudden the guy
like starts scanning yeah
he reaches down and pulls out a 45
bro and i'm like 50 meters away
and
i go excuse so the guys i just go excuse
me sir you know because i'm we're in
america like this guy doesn't know what
the hell is going on man i'm like excuse
me sir sir you know sir it's okay i said
we're in the military we're on a
training operation but it was uh not a
good scenario to have yeah
there was lots of uh things like that
you know especially in the urban side
um a good friend of mine they called him
the sf cowboy they use his likeness in
that video game and all that i don't
know if you remember some of the first
pictures that came out of afghanistan
big dude sleeves cut off big old beard
he was my roommate right
well we're sitting in a little minivan
right watching this house
and freaking i'm like oh crap it's like
two in the morning you know and freaking
dude walks up
oh [__] revolver pointing at us and
we're like whoa whoa whoa whoa
freaking rolls it down most of the time
we had a law enforcement guy with us but
in this case it was him and i and the
law enforcement dudes were in another
car up the road and now it's like hey
bro hey hey hey hey well he's just a
concerned citizen you know what i mean
and when lucky you know that could have
gone so bad can you imagine the headline
right like say one of us made a mistake
and put him on the dirt you know
american civilian
yeah and you know so simpson i've done a
couple of things where i'm advising law
enforcement in the states minneapolis
right a couple year year before last
right when that whole mess kicked off
and it's like hey man
i don't care if you're far left i don't
care if you're blm and rioting right
you're an american
i'm not squeezing the trigger on
american right you can't wrong answer
now if you're threatening me that's
different but just hey man if you're
robbing and looting a best buy
to me that's not something i can pull
the trigger on somebody for man it's
just not in my in my book
and it's weird you know it's weird like
you have to remind guys like hey guys
this is not an operation we are here in
advisement only only if
you have done everything you can
to get out of that situation
and it's defensive yourself for third
party man right like it because the
backlash of something like that would be
huge
you know there was those um there was
that old the border
surveillance thing oh yeah marines shot
that guy like the late 90s i don't know
i forgot the name of the it was it had
an operational name
yeah they sent all kinds of guys down
yeah yeah and the marines shot that one
fella and that was a big deal and they
shut that program down um and we were
kind of like a part of that same
umbrella um
but yeah we always used to you know joke
and it's not really that funny now that
i'm older that you know yeah pos pasi
como tadas you know now i look back and
i'm like should
the military and the agency be allowed
to advise
because let's face it right like
um in waco
there were tier one advisors on the
ground
you know
that that stuff that's kind of scary man
you know because
you know the rule of law says that our
intelligence organizations and our
military can't operate here of course
the national guard gets around it a
little bit with that state mission
but it's scary right there's a reason
possible exists so that military can't
turn its weapons towards our population
so looking back like i i'm like man we
were we were kids we were joking like
man possibilities now i'm like
it's not funny anymore right like you
know when you're when you're young and
dumb you make jokes that are
inappropriate because you're young and
dumb and now i look back i'm like i
don't know that we should be doing that
right like
i know law enforcement needs help but
yeah there's probably shouldn't be
getting it from us there's definitely a
i don't know there's a positive and
negative to it too because obviously if
you have guys that can help law
enforcement improve their what they do
like that's beneficial
and then there's two two sides of that
coin too because
guys that are in the military have a
certain mindset part of that mindset is
hey man we've been through this before
somebody gets starts getting crazy we're
not worried about it we're not freaking
out like we'll de-escalate
in many cases de-escalate better than
someone that hasn't been in these shitty
situations before
but then not all military is created
equal so you might get someone from the
same unit that goes if somebody does
that [__] you gotta freaking go and
you're like no actually that's not the
right answer so
it that there's a there can be a
positive there can be a negative
uh that both those situations you could
have somebody from the military perform
awesome
you could also have someone from the
military do something stupid i mean just
because you're in the military doesn't
mean you're
it doesn't mean it doesn't it doesn't
mean [__] they're all over the map you
know all over the map some guys
tactically they were in the military for
20 years they're tactical idiots
you know i've gotten that a couple times
with the whole campaign like well just
because you're a veteran doesn't mean
you're and i'm like you're absolutely
right
being a veteran doesn't mean that i was
even good at being a military guy
right like just because you were in the
service doesn't mean you're even good at
whatever your job was in the service so
it definitely doesn't automatically
qualify you to be a politician uh in a
lot of ways
i feel like my experiences completely
make me unqualified to be a
typical politician yeah right like i'm
what i'm kind of getting at here is that
yeah i'm not a politician and never have
been and that's what our country needs
right now
and my experiences in the military
have set me up to where i could go do
good things for our country and never
become a politician i don't have that in
my blood it's just not how i am yeah as
i look at
everything that's going on the last
six months after the downfall of
afghanistan and then even looking at
afghanistan iraq and then you just
compare all that to vietnam and you say
to yourself
like like those lessons every lesson
that we you can look back at afghanistan
and say wow you know we learned this we
already knew this we already knew this
stuff from vietnam
and so when it comes to people being in
the government that are figuring out
where we're going to war
i used to think yeah you know somebody
should somebody should uh be in the
military if they're going to serve in in
the government you know if they're going
to be a politician they should have they
should have served in the military it's
be helpful right i used to think that
like oh yeah that makes sense like oh
yeah okay yeah that makes sense you
understand what continued service yeah
continued service like oh yeah you know
what it's like but
now i'm we absolutely
need military people
that are that understand these lessons
to the core that aren't just thinking
with the arrogance that
that the generation that just sent us to
war
let's fight we'll fight for american
principles and but
or even more who's going to fight right
you say we who's the wheat oh no no not
we yeah right yeah those militaries yeah
those military guys
it funny right
you'll hear about folks who had these
awesome blessed lives maybe
um
like tillman nfl football player you
hear these crazy stories about these
people who had these awesome jobs or
maybe they came from this awesome family
and they go and he enlisted
right like it's automatically assumed
because he came from a an amazing family
that he should have been an officer
right like that prejudice is weird so
the fact that a rich well-to-do guy
enlists and goes to fight for that's a
story why is that a story that shouldn't
be a story but it is
right and i just use tillman because
he's such a famous story
and what what an amazing man you know
freaking
pro football player you know life is set
for this guy quits that and listen to
ranger retro right like whoa bro you
really asking for it like that's some
american stuff but my point is who's
going to war
typically it's just those young
what else did you have to do with your
life type of guys you know and and guys
like a lot of us right let's face it you
know a lot of upper middle class dudes
and soft you know and
you know but and feel that calling that
i need to do this stuff
because their dad lets them watch rambo
when they're a kid
right
but um
yeah man
congress
right
is the only part of our government
per the constitution
that can declare war
how is it we've been at war for 20 years
what's the point what was the point
right because in in
jalalabad which has been considered for
10 12 years now a hot spot right
but in
january february march of 2002 i was
walking around the market without a gun
i'd hop on the atv and jump in the truck
hop in the car with one of my troopers
one of my afghanis
run down wearing afghani garb
the biggest threat to me in that market
or anywhere in jalalabad or all of
nangahara province
was having the people
hug me too tightly that was the biggest
threat to me
or maybe a car accident because
traffic's crazy you know they loved us
they loved us so what happened
the conventional military showed up so
all the colonels and generals can get
their stars and their awards and get
their promotions
those politicians because let's face it
right
once you become
a certain level
whether it's enlisted or officer right
your career becomes that thing and then
looking out for your other
you know upper
senior officer senior enlisted
got to get them bronze stars we got imp
purple hearts our unit needs metals our
unit needs combat because you know to
become a general without a cib in the
army in this time frame you got to go
get some right and you're going to
probably need a silver star at least a
bronze star would be
so how am i gonna do that unless i go to
war so let's take these strikers and
these m2 bradleys and
destroy roads and run over innocent
people
and they weren't doing it on purpose
they're just
that's the conventional military they
have tanks and you know i've never
driven a striker before but i've sat in
a hatch i'm like how can you drive this
thing without running over everything
you know and they're like well you do
run over everything because it
can well you know what man we made those
enemies
we made the enemies
then we're now fighting the second
generation we're fighting the sons of
the men we killed
in torah we're fighting the sons and the
men we killed in the shahika and helmand
and everywhere else at the beginning of
that war
we created that enemy and the same thing
happened in iraq
and you know let's face it right
afghanistan was righteous you know i
kind of needed to fall
i looking back is it a good strategy
to topple regimes that are predictable
the taliban was very predictable the
taliban has never
met the requirement to be listed as a
terrorist organization they were a
sovereign nation
and yes they had horrible horrible
means and human rights abuses but they
were a sovereign nation
gaddafi
sovereign nation
freaking iraq sovereign nation with
dictators and dictators are predictable
they care about one thing first and
foremost their main priority is their
power so they're predictable
you know in the interviews with saddam
you know he talks about like i thought
y'all were kidding
he was like i i thought you were making
it up that you thought i had weapons of
mass destruction i haven't had gas in
years i don't have any of that stuff in
his interviews you know he's going i
really didn't think y'all were going to
invade
so why did we
i have my own theories my theory is
because people say we went to war for
oil
i'm like
have you seen the oil prices
we didn't go for oil we went to war with
iraq to stop its oil production the
prices went up
because if we pumped oil out of iraq we
would have made all the oil companies
would have made money
right because that's a new source that
we didn't they didn't have
rights or access to
you stop the oil
all right
lower the supply demand stays at or
continues to increase
prices go up
so that's a little bit of my theory on
that but whatever either way at least
and that's only based off of what i have
seen since right when we first invaded
that right
let's go you know like every other
little young trooper
but really you know we're talking
hundreds of thousands of iraqis
thousands of americans and and what did
we get
right if you tell me you know because
war was supposed to be ex for expansion
um
minerals riches right throughout human
history war has been to expand your
empire
well we suck at being an imperial power
because we go to these wars and we do
nothing with the spoils
so why do we keep sending americans
because let's face it was it really for
our national defense or was it for our
national interests
because that's two very different things
most of my work throughout my life has
been for interests less about defense
because once al qaeda was destroyed and
eliminated and even isis and al-qaida in
iraq
were they ever really capable
of attacking us here
yeah you know they flew the planes into
those towers and killed 3 000 plus
people
but did they ever really threaten our
daily lives did they threaten america
the united states probably not
you know
right could they ever have brought that
war on a large scale to america and
affected the average americans their
life no they didn't have that capability
and after i mean clearly right like
none of that's really
we haven't had any big attacks since 9
11. i think they just blew their wad
they were done they didn't really i
don't think they had any plan after that
right he's like oh no crap now what we
pissed these guys off and they're coming
for us
now what right they never really
did anything since
so my point is right like
where has congress been where has our
representatives in our senate been these
last 20 years
the military industrial complex
continues to make big time money big
time money
when our enlisted soldiers are in
barracks
that are covered in mold just nastiness
right they're living in poverty
whereas you can go to the general's
house on any post and it's a
well-groomed
lawn and it's basically a little mansion
right
so so what did we get out of these wars
well it's arguable right it's very
arguable but the bottom line is
congress
has continued to set aside its authority
its duty its role its responsibility
to either declare war or cut the funding
they didn't cut the funding a lot of
people got rich off these wars and i
mean i was a contractor i
guilty i
i got paid for going to war
now did i get paid like glock or
you know northrop or raytheon or
no of course not
but
well you got a positive outlook believe
it or not from my perspective because
the positive outlook would be that
somebody was smart enough to figure out
that if they did this stuff uh they'd be
able to
raise the price of oil and these other i
i that's to me that's a positive outlook
to think that someone was smart enough
to actually craft the things that you're
saying right i don't know if they
actually it was playing or if it just we
didn't stumble into it here's what yeah
because i worry about they people are at
least conspiracy theories i'm like half
time they can't figure out where the
bathroom is that's what makes that's
what that's what disturbs me more than
anything else is that it's the arrogance
combined with the
being naive the naive to think okay
here's what's going on iraq
look
we know that saddam's not a good guy we
can probably create some kind of a good
ally there and we can probably just turn
this into a democracy because we like
democracy and we you know we like it and
all those people must want to be free
too and we've got people that came from
iraq or that are in iraq that say hell
yeah we want to be free so cool
let's invade and in their minds it plays
out hey it's going to be like the first
gulf war it'll take us you know a couple
weeks then we'll start to we'll get rid
of the bath party we'll establish we'll
start building walmarts right that i
think that that's what they thought more
than anything else probably
and it's just it's just an arrogant it's
just arrogance it's well it's not just
arrogance it's arrogance and it's
ignorance to think that you can go and
you know there's a
when it comes to the economy right when
you start trying to dictate when you
start having a centralized economy it's
you cannot pull it off you can't do it
you can't pull off a centralized economy
that's why communism doesn't work
you have to let the free market kind of
do its thing
so if you think if you if you if we know
that you can't control an economy which
is a finite thing and a controllable
thing in some in some feasible way
and we can't control it but at least you
can understand what it is but now we
think we're going to take a bunch of
millions of people and predict how
they're going to respond and predict
what the secondary tertiary effects are
going to be with what they think and how
they're going to behave like that's
completely insane to think that
we we think we're going to control the
future with other people we think we
understand what they're doing we we
can't
so we have to start behaving in a way
that we we utilize our power
to make to attempt to influence but we
can't think to ourselves that the things
are gonna play out the way we think
they're gonna play out because they
don't
they don't they couldn't even figure out
these two freaking guys in afghanistan
one of them's from england
hey everyone's going to listen this guy
meanwhile there's a local here that's
been running [__] for years and we think
this other guy's going to fly in from
england he speaks english he must be
smart everyone's going to listen to him
no
no and then you just play that out over
and over and over again in a bunch of
different scenarios in iraq and in
afghanistan and in iraq and that's what
you end up with so that's why i'm
so happy that guys like you are stepping
up people that understand that we don't
understand right people that understand
that we can't control everything people
understand that the enemy gets a vote
the civilians get to vote like all those
things come into play
and we run around like we can figure it
all out nothing is two plus two equals
four right it's always an equation with
hundreds if not thousands of variables
and any time you change one variable
to get the continued result you're gonna
have to change every variable or many of
them right and americans we a couple are
you know that arrogance right so what is
i always say arrogance is ignorance and
cockiness combined
and and lord knows we are a lot of
ignorance and then you've got the
cockiness
and we think we really think that people
want 5g or 4g or 3g or whatever it was
10 years ago they want that but you got
this culture that no one wants to bother
to understand who understands the
culture of the afghanis who understands
the culture of the yazidi in northern
iraq or the kurds in
very north iraq or the shia in
southeastern who understands this stuff
the guy on the ground
the guy on the ground you know we were
talking about you know um
are you familiar with uh lieutenant
colonel stuart sheller yeah the marine
corps he was on the podcast yeah he was
on the pockets right right yeah i
haven't talked to in a couple weeks he
and i went down to the border
and um i told him i was like hey bro i
gotta say uh he and i joke about how we
met we we talked through it we were on
with uh evan and jt with a black rifle
and
and we were talking about how we met
it's a pretty funny story
but um
we went down there
and we talked with a border patrol agent
who's a very good friend of mine and uh
of course off unofficial
because he would get fired for even
entertaining having a conversation with
a congressional candidate or house of
representatives candidate
but he talked to us and he showed us
some places we could go and look before
and broke it down for us
nothing in the media
that i had heard
was anything like the border really is
at least in this section in this section
of texas around roma and rio grande city
and it was just nothing like i thought
because we were on the ground
that fellow that border patrol agent
he's the guy on the ground i just went
and got some info from him and then we
went driving around and stuff and looked
and everything he told us was exactly
the way it was and i was like holy crap
man
but the border patrol's on basically a
gag order man they talk to somebody
their job's over
done all right so yeah man uh
colonel scheller and i the funny thing
is man he i got word that he might run
for house
you know he went out of the marine corps
yet
and uh
it's like
and i hadn't announced yet either
so
a friend of ours
some mutual friend a major who had
worked for
colonel um i reached out i was like hey
he's like hey zach gave me your number
says you want to talk to me like yes sir
you know um
our career paths may be about to collide
be nice if we could just meet face to
face and chat he was like okay well i'm
up in emerald are you willing to come up
here yep house tomorrow morning
sat down and was like
here you think about running in the
fourth and he would
because apparently at that time he had
told two people the fact that i knew it
blew him away he's like whoa who is this
dude you know luckily my team uh my
consulting team are very well connected
and super smart guys or whatever so
anyway we sat and chatted it was really
cool conversation i'm talking about
mature adult conversation because he
could have easily been like you know an
arrogant
dick and been like whatever i'll run
against whoever i want but we said hmm
we're two very similar
types do we really need to run against
each other
i live in the fourth he doesn't and now
it's not the fourth anymore but we can
get to that
and i was just a really cool
conversation a little coffee shop there
in emerald island north carolina and we
left it with and i just you know i
gained a lot of respect for the man when
he was like okay i tell you what i'm
gonna think this over i don't even know
if i'm gonna get out of the marine corps
enough time to even
you know get in the race blah blah blah
i'm gonna take it over
um
he's like when are you gonna announce on
this eight he's like okay well two days
prior i'll let you know so at least then
you'll know if we're running against
each other i'm like
roger that thanks anyway the marine
corps
didn't work out or whatever and it
didn't work out for him
i would like to think he'll run in 2024
you know um i know he's considering it a
lot can happen in two years but um
yeah man what a what a good guy man he's
definitely a marine corps officer right
like you know you guys talked with him
right he is
ra you know but that we need some of
that man we need some of that i mean
that dude threw his
17 almost 18-year career
out the window to just stand up and say
something which is funny because like i
hear and see people on the internet like
condemning for it and i'm like enlisted
guys i'm like fellas
we have been begging pleading wishing
a colonel
would stand up and now you are trying to
say this this man is doing it for
recognition like just sit down and talk
to him for two minutes and you'll find
it out not so much
but yeah we we were uh we're in roma
texas and uh we found out we're looking
like the people aren't coming across the
border in the middle of the desert
they're coming across like the bridge
that goes across there's the border
patrol checkpoint at roma they're
walking under the bridge coming up
hitting the cul-de-sac and every night
they get picked up by the border patrol
buses and taking entertainment facility
they're not stinking across in the
middle of the desert walking right up
into town sitting down getting picked up
every night that's been going on for
months
right this whole
shipping around the nation thing that's
not new it's been going on for months i
had no idea those headlines had just
broke the day before i was like holy
crap when did this start happening my
buddy was like bro we've been shipping
illegals around this country for nine
months bro
he's like the numbers are down
well yeah he's like yeah it was 2 000
coming across the border in this little
section
every night he goes and then the cartels
figured out
and they all figured out right that
the board patrol can only pick up about
200 at night
so now only 200 a night come across
on the other side on the mic side of the
border they have warehouses or hotels
and it costs to stay there
but they only let 200 each night so the
cartel
the cost to come across the border not
not being ferried not good coyote
not transportation the cartels tax or
fee to walk across the border to get
your armband
so you can walk across the border it's
like
armband but the cartel gives them an
armband legit
an armband on our side
nothing but trash armbands
it's like going into a club you pay you
get your armband you're clear to go
across
well and armbands are color coded from
which country you come from because in
those warehouses that you can see from
america right over there on the mic side
they're basically hotels or it's just
cots and floor mats
every night you stay there is a hundred
dollars to walk across that borders 900
to 1200 according where you for where
you come from
or if you don't want to spend a couple
nights in that hotel warehouse
you can pay more but that's what it
costs
in texas alone last year 1.7 million
illegal immigrants illegal crosses of
our border
were detained
that's just how many were detained in
texas just texas that's how many were
detained now how many people came on
across
and this whole evolution of the book
border patrol and customs facilitating
the integration and
faring throughout the country it used to
be you know coyotes would continue and
pick up
we destroyed that business and gave it
all the cartels so
1.7 million let's say a thousand bucks
times a thousand dollars
and we can only guess that double that
we're not in detain so let's just call
it an even three mil times a thousand
dollars that's what we gave the cartels
just in mexico
when i say we gave it to them we created
this marketplace for them
that's what this administration did by
opening the borders they created a
marketplace where the cartels now they
don't really even care about drugs
the drugs that are coming across our
border now are coming across in a
backpack not truckloads there's no more
marijuana coming across in truckloads
that's very they're not seizing
marijuana anymore it's backpacks of
fentanyl and heroin
because 30 pound backpack of fentanyl
i can damn near kill the whole east
coast
stuff is so potent
30 40 pounds of black tar unprocessed
opium hash bring it to the stage
processing the heroin one backpack turns
into freaking half a million dollars
worth of heroin
how do we combat that if we don't get
serious about true border security
and even beyond that right because the
lord knows that's one of my problems
with
americans but republicans more so that
everything's a linear solution build a
wall
and then what
no one's asking and then what
so we build this wall we're gonna do put
guns on it people are like yeah okay so
we're gonna shoot our southern neighbors
who want to come to america
okay
i don't blame them for wanting to come
here but there's a line
in the back of it there's a line to come
here
so yes it's got to be multifaceted right
it can't be just build a wall
that's not solving the problem that's
just a measure to slow part of the
result of the problem the illegal
immigration why are neighbors wanting to
come here so badly because all our
southern neighbors their countries are
crap
had we adhered to the monroe doctrine
and quit worried about europe and quit
worrying about the middle east i mean we
spent billions in millions what if we
had invested that in our southern
neighbors instead of letting say i don't
know one of the richest richest
wealthiest countries in the world
venezuela
fault of communism right underneath our
noses
why why did we do that why are we not
actually helping mexico
oh we want to take these hard lines and
look like a bunch of tough guys it's not
solving the problem
and it kills me that that's that's all
all these solutions right when you like
all my opponents across the nation if
you if you talk to republican candidates
for any office from city council
probably to the next president they're
going to have one linear solution for
any problem you talk to them about
because what talking points
but no one's actually discussing root
causes of problems
so the border security
a wall is a measure not a solution
it's not it's not going to solve the
problem you build a wall well there's
these two bodies of water on each side
of it right
you know the deal
there's not a single security measure
put on this planet
you whatever you build whatever security
protocol you build
there's guys like us that can get around
it right it's just like lawyers right
lawyers can write a bunch of legal
documents and then some other lawyers
can figure out how to screw that
it's the same thing in that warfare it's
like
your enemy does this they set up these
obstacles you figure out how to get
around them
well here's an idea
let's address it at its root cause and
i don't know
maybe the demand to come here
well
let's say 20 years from now oh my god
and that's not an american thing right
20 years from now next election cycle
only four years old right americans
think in four year blocks if we're lucky
what if 20 years from now mexico is a
thriving
ally
and there's no cartels we help them get
rid of it we give them incentives to
stop
teaming up with the cartels
same goes for panama costa rica
nicaragua el salvador we help them with
the game problems we help them and i
don't mean just toss money at it and
waste money when i say invest right
invest means
there's a
implied return on that investment right
americans
when our congress just allocates funds
they just throw money at things they
don't actually follow up or have
measures in place to ensure our return
on investment
so my point here is man that that's part
of why i'm running is i'm so tired of
these very linear
band-aids to hemorrhaging wounds
you know
and
the the wall is just one great example
of that you know i mean name any other
hot topic right now
abortion ban it
the same people that say banning
abortion will solve that problem the
same people that will tell you that
banning guns won't get rid of guns
where's the logic and reason here folks
so like with abortion yeah man it's it's
horrible right i mean even people who
are pro-choice will go yeah it's bad
there's very only the craziest of the
crazy or like for abortion right that's
that's
human beings are not for killing unborn
children
generally speaking
so
why are we having abortions
right
let's make them illegal okay cool let's
make them illegal we're done but we're
not done because we haven't addressed
why are we why are
women
wanting
or feeling the need to abort their
unborn child
first of all
the three of us will never ever be able
to
understand sympathize with a woman
that is so desperate
that she wants to abort her child right
it's just first of all we have to say
that out loud right
so let's bring in the experts
let's talk to some ladies i know that
sounds crazy right let's go find the
subject matter experts and figure out
why this is happening
well
i ask people all the time what's the
number one demographic in america having
abortions
do you guys know put you on the spot
right
yeah i was a little surprised too 17 to
22 year old upper middle class white
women
why
well
because their fathers have told them
they need to go to college because
modern feminism had told them they need
to go to college they need to get
careers
and a child inhibits that
right and and this is a very
summarized version of this very very
complex problem
so
what if we
as a community as a government right
it's okay for the government to do
things for the community right like we
can we can have some good social
welfare problems right things that
support the wellness of our communities
and our culture and our nation
so when i use welfare i don't mean just
throwing money at stuff and not
expecting some type of return
so
if we start saying okay what if
we create a robust and efficient
adoption program what if there's
assistance for these women
to carry their children to terms instead
of terminating them what if
and i say what if because i don't know
the answer right and that's that's weird
for a political candidate to tell you he
doesn't know for sure what he's talking
about right but we know that right we
come up with courses of actions
and then
say okay we're going to do this and then
we try to anticipate
what our adversary is going to do if we
do x they'll do y and then this is how
well that's how we have to
war game all these things right
so if we sit down and say okay because
here's a here's a really bad thing about
the adoption process in america today
memeless are not married right we see
marriage as an agreement between she and
i and god
not the state of north carolina
also she's a very pragmatic practical
person and she wants to hold the whole
thing that if she gets tired of me she
can just boot me or walk away how long
have you all been together 10 and a half
years
we're married in my eyes my heart my
soul i'm married to that woman and she's
the most precious thing on this planet
to me
right like precious he's the only one
that's how precious she is
so
if she and i wanted to adopt it could
take three to five years
if me and you want to adopt
right we could have a kid in a year or
less that's how our cultures evolve now
right a gay couple can
adopt very quickly
it doesn't make any sense
it doesn't make any sense or
maybe melissa could go out of the
country and buy a child we could adopt
from africa or china let's face it
you're buying a child when you do that
because it costs a lot of money but you
can do it and you can do it in a matter
of weeks
typically speaking when someone adopts
out of africa
different countries different way right
but you go over you visit
you come back you go back to the next
trip and you have your child
it's efficient and it's a good thing
right like these are
these are parents who want children who
can't have them for whatever reason
and then there are these children that
need parents
we have so many in america but so why
are americans leaving america the united
states who go adopt children from other
countries when we have kids right here
we have an abortion problem
why
because it's easier
you know like let's face it right i mean
let's say let's say melissa couldn't
have kids right that's not why we don't
have kids we don't have kids because
it's just kind of a choice we've been
busy she's been busy with her career and
i've been busy with mine
and
so
if
we wanted to it takes time
right but we could go get a kid it
doesn't it doesn't make any sense
so my point to all that is whether it's
the border or abortion or
name it
you've got all these candidates and
these politicians right because right
now a lot of politicians sitting already
elected politicians they're now
candidates again midterms are coming
they have these one-liners these talking
points
and then they go back to dc and they
don't really do anything
it's so frustrating to me man because
let's face it right we're problem
solvers you know we're given problems
every single day whether it's how to fit
that much equipment on that one truck
because that other truck is deadlined
right or supply won't give us another
truck you know because it's some smart
major who needs that truck
um for his ride to the chow hall or
whatever you know
we solve problems with very little and
then
at this point in our nation's
history and future present and future
you know we we need those type of people
we need
guys
from our community and and gals from
the global war on terrorism those type
of veterans who are problem solvers
who have seen you know the neglect and
the abuse and the fraud waste and abuse
that's what these wars have been you
know afghanistan highlights it but
people don't realize how many billions
of dollars of equipment we left in iraq
too
that we had to destroy in syria because
they isis took it drove it across the
border and then fought us with it but
there's still billions upon billions of
dollars of equipment in iraq
now we haven't abandoned iraq
we have been in iraq too it was just
less publicized less emotional
for a lot of the servicemen and women
because of
just the way afghanistan happened so
quickly it was really easy for the media
to cover
so on and so forth and then all the
debacle in kabul at the airfield that
was definitely
the media loved
it was a disastrous you know
show
iraq happened over a course of numerous
years and they're not interested in
covering that kind of stuff
so anyway
the uh
one thing i talk about a lot when i talk
about leadership i wrote about in one of
my books iterative decision making
process which means
you don't know necessarily what's going
to happen and you don't necessarily have
all the information so what do you do
you sit there and just do nothing no you
go okay well here's a step that i think
this might have an impact a positive
impact let me try this one step right
you try that one step then you get what
the feedback is if the feedback is good
you say okay well that was good let's do
a little bit more in that direction okay
great oh it's still working that's super
oh let's try a little bit more in that
direction oh wait a second now we're
getting negative feedback what we
thought was gonna happen isn't happening
do we double down no we actually say oh
let's make some adjustments to what our
plan what our strategy is
and that that's what was
as you look at uh afghanistan and iraq
and vietnam
you can see
inflection points along the way where
the the direction we were going
was not clearly giving good feedback now
do you immediately abandon it no maybe
press okay let's try a little bit more
let's make some adjustments oh wait a
second oh wait it's definitely not
working right okay so what should we do
we should try a different plan we should
try a different strategy and we
shouldn't be afraid to say you know what
we were wrong about this
and we are going to back out
and we are going to provide a different
type of effort to try and solve this
problem
so like you said a lot of politicians a
lot of that's just politicians people
human beings
don't want to say hey
i messed up here i was wrong about this
here's my adjustments here's what we're
going to do
i'm open to ideas covet
when it first happened all of us were
like whoa okay um yeah man i started
carrying some hand sanitizer
i
you know
i put melissa a go bag together for the
first time right i'm not a i'm not
really a prepper i'm more of a well of
chittis fan i've got enough that i'll be
able to make it right
i'm good right i'm mentally prepped you
know um she drives back and forth to
wilmington you know an hour so i was
like you know what you know she she
competes in three gun and she's doing
some of the tactical games and all that
kind of stuff and i mean she can shoot
right she goes to range by herself and
all that you know she's got her own m4
and all that kind of stuff so we
actually packed it up through a little
72-hour go bag in her trunk right we
were all like this pandemic might be
something
within about six weeks we were like
and we all knew like these cloth mats
right like we've all done sea burn right
we've all done some counter
proliferation of biological nuclear and
those those suits and the gas masks and
all this stuff right it's like
that might stop a virus that might and
now you're telling me this mask is what
we all knew it was just horseshoes
nowhere i got a handkerchief all i'm
good right
and and i think maybe like you said like
with the right we you know i don't think
they really
like it it started out good in
intentions yeah and like you said about
afghanistan when we when we got to iraq
there was there was iraqis waving
american flags and welkin missed there
and
they wanted us to be there and even i
was there in 2003 2004 2006 all the way
that through that time there was the the
local iraqi populace wanted us there and
by the way in 2012-13
and when isis started to to flex
there was there was plenty of iraqi
government officials and people on the
ground saying please america please come
help us hey we need some help over here
we weren't thinking that these guys
would come back but here they are and we
need some help please come help us
so
we can't ignore the part of the
population
that wants that right when you cause a
problem you're kind of obligated to deal
with it right we caused that problem in
iraq i was all four with withdrawal and
the obama administration their
withdrawal but once they decided they
were going to withdraw there came a
point when isis rose up that we needed
to halt the withdrawal deal with isis
and then pick back up with the
withdrawal but since they started to
withdraw they couldn't say they made a
mistake americans will never we just
don't like to say we're wrong i told
somebody the other day i was like i will
kiss your white ass
live on whatever social media platform
you want to go live on if you can find
me a politician an elected official that
has said you know what i realized now i
was wrong and
find me one politician who has said that
yeah and the the crazy thing is from an
ego perspective people think if i say
hey guys i was wrong about this you
think everyone's gonna think you're a
loser now no they actually go yeah well
cool i'm glad you admitted that and we
didn't know either like like you were
bringing up the example of covid
hey okay it looks like a bunch of people
in italy are dying they're showing these
pictures of people uh dying in the
hospitals they're all overcrowded this
looks like it's gonna suck cool oh you
want us to stand down for a few weeks
here cool we're gonna flatten the curve
what does that mean oh we don't want our
hospitals overwhelmed okay got it we
need time to prepare sure sounds good
okay
now we need another two weeks okay hey
you know what i'm american i support
america i want to have people get here
okay cool got it
well now you want another two weeks now
you want to know two months now you want
another six months now you want another
year and then after a year we find out
that the death rates
you know most of the people aren't dying
from code they're dying from something
else and and covet accelerated it and
that's fine i get it you know
but it we have now have information and
data right that says all the measures
that we did they didn't help we've got a
vaccine that really isn't right by you
know they had to change the definition
of vaccine yeah
right like
could you imagine getting three polio
vaccines and then getting polio
yeah that's not right we got rid of that
that vaccine got rid of that disease
right this vaccine supposedly makes your
symptoms less
but it could kill you yeah
right like
that's one that's this one um one drug
we haven't seen commercials for right
because all those drug commercials in tv
is like when they when they get into the
fine print they start speaking really
fast about all the the side effects it's
like and it could kill you know you
could have crazy diarrhea and you could
bleed from your nose and maybe your anus
and then you might very well die from
this
kidney failure you know and people were
like oh okay but ask your doctor
but your skin will be clearer after two
weeks
right
could you imagine what the johnson and
johnson vaccine got pulled right why
shh let's not talk about that let's just
talk about another accent because of
that jay's vaccine killed some people
american people don't even know
so many people don't even know the
johnson johnson vaccine was pulled and
that it had killed people with strokes
and you know fancier medical terms than
i know
huh
right like we won't just step back and
say hey we now have different
information we're going to adjust this
plan yeah and by the way on that
you can say hey
there are here's the fine print on the
vaccine here's what it can do to hear
the side effects you can have and make a
choice you know as a human being if you
have some compromised immune system or
you're living in some situation where
this covid
according to all the statistics could be
really bad for you maybe that vaccine is
a godsend that's awesome maybe a mask is
great for you yeah but if you're a
person that's young and healthy and you
feel like you could oh and you know
a bunch of people that have had it and
it didn't impact them at all and you say
hey i don't think i'm going to need that
vaccine it doesn't seem like it's worth
the risk so that's my decision right so
you let people make a decision about
what they're going to do with their
health
that seems like a much smarter move
than trying to impose things on people
which i've gone off on this a bunch when
you try and impose things on human
beings
we fight especially americans they don't
like it we don't like it but all human
beings don't like it all human beings
don't like to have things imposed on
them
and the only way you can impose things
effectively is to do it through force
through violence or now we're recently
finding out that you can also do it by
by taking their money and seizing their
assets before they can even know what's
happening right
which i never i never really thought of
that before it didn't even occur to me
that like what's going on in canada
right now oh you're gonna protest cool
we're not just gonna arrest you we're
gonna seize your assets
that to me is like when you come to my
property and you say you're going to
take my house
exactly the same thing i'm right
so that is a problem
in canada it's just so hard to watch
you got
law enforcement guys who just a few
years ago or not even two years ago
they were being defunded and demonized
you know during the whole black lives
matter thing and now these same police
officers are the ones that are
literally trampling
on on people and i was
like you know please god don't let it
come to that here because i have a lot
of law enforcement brothers and we all
know that good men follow orders
and good men that need to take care of
their children will follow orders could
mean they have to take care of their
family rely on that paycheck they're
going to follow orders
that is scary to me because it will be
at that point when i'm like hey law dogs
i love you
and i've always supported you
but we are now on two different sides
right like when you s
like what's happening in canada man they
are siding with trudeau
that little turd
and i usually don't i try not to talk
about
presidents
elected especially elected presidents of
sovereign nations in that kind of
derogatory term but wow
you want to talk about someone that
won't admit that he's wrong
and double down on it every every step
it's like i just won't lose and he's got
an arsenal he's got a military he's got
a national police force man the national
police force scares the [__] out of me
dude i don't like it when i see feds
wearing multicam and military stuff
right like it makes me uneasy i don't
like seeing local pds wearing bdus
right i wanna i like some shine shoes
like north carolina highway patrol still
wears a police uniform they look like
police officers not military members
i still don't like it man even though i
want my law dog friends to have every
tool available to them to do
law enforcement
but there's some things that i
definitely i'm not cool with like no
knock warrants and stuff like that yeah
they're not necessary and we learned
that cqb is dangerous
let's just knock cordon come out yeah oh
you don't want to come out okay cool
just turn your power off yeah we'll play
some loud music maybe send a robot in
with some gas you'll come out you'll get
tired of this right yeah the no knock
warrant thing is is definitely something
that needs to stop yeah our law
enforcement needs some help right yeah
it really does across america law
enforcement in general needs help the
average law adult is a good good
american yeah
and even up in canada i don't think that
i don't think it's going to continue in
this direction the direction that's
going right now i don't think it's going
to continue in this direction i think
it's going to
yeah i think it's going to stop i think
the only reason
that that's is what's going to happen is
that the people that are pressing like
trudeau they're actually just a bunch of
[__]
they think they want to fight
but
you know do they really want to fight
once the bullets start flying and stuff
you know and things get pressed i i
think ultimately we're going to see
trudeau step down i just looked at my uh
watch to recognize the date so it's the
20th it's the 21st of february when
we're recording this right now so it'll
be interesting yeah be interesting to
see how it all washes out i you know i
hope that's what happened i do not want
to see canadians shooting canadians no
more than i want to see americans
shooting americans
you know even like
you know americans are still mad about
the whole riots and the black lives
matter stuff and rightfully so because
it was all perpetuated and funded
you know black lives matter is that
those folks on the streets rioting they
were pawns of rich people
and that's that's sad right because
sometimes i feel like we've been a
little bit of pawned out in the war so i
can kind of relate
i'm not mad
at young
black or young hispanic or whatever
group or even even young antifa you know
white kids who are riding and breaking
stuff they're pissed
are they going too far absolutely right
we have the right to protest peacefully
but not break [__] and set it on fire
it's wrong that's rioting not protesting
again root cause that whole mess was
perpetuated
it was funded i mean there were pallets
of bricks that just poof showed up and
you know
what's the root cause what's the root
cause man what's really going on how do
we
reach out to
even more so you know like
our poor communities poor inner city
communities which oftentimes are
predominantly black but also latino your
your poor white communities tend to be
raw right
well why are these things happening what
what is the perpetual process that that
keeps these communities in their
situation well
the modern welfare system and and i
don't mean the good kind of welfare like
wellness of society i'm talking about
our the ebt and and all these things
there's no there's no
it it doesn't help people get out of
those situation it perpetuates it
it it destroys the nuclear family and it
was you know we can go back to lbj you
know with the modern welfare programs
and there's plenty of quotes out there
that they did it on purpose they knew
what they actually planned that stuff
right like i think back in the 50s and
60s the intelligence agency and our
government they were pretty sinister and
they were thoughtful they weren't just
meandering right and you can go back and
look at what they did and how they
approached it and lyndon baines johnson
nixon that whole bunch that were raised
out of world war ii
in a fear of socialism and communism
you know
that fbi hoover's fbi that cia you know
i mean man it was they were proficient i
feel like they knew what they were doing
and so they created that welfare problem
and here we are today no one's ever
really came up with any decent solutions
the only real welfare reform our nation
has ever seen actually came from
clinton
he actually proposed some things that
would help
the inner city
become
more productive
involved citizens
and then all that expired and no one's
done anything since and
i think it's funny you know you got the
democrats who
manipulate
and coerce
those communities for votes and you got
republicans who are just like it's not
even worth it to talk to them they're
just going to vote democrat
and i'm like
recruitment 101 folks
you've got young angry people
that the system's not working for let's
go talk to them
let's come up with a real welfare reform
how do you root problems right that's
another one right
just cut off welfare tell them to get
jobs
that's the
average white man in america's freaking
answer to welfare and poor inner city
problems cut it off tell them to get
jobs
yeah okay but now we're talking about
decades and generations
cultural
change
we have cultures that are based around
this problem
you think you can just turn off welfare
and just only get jobs there's your
answer that's it
okay and then what
i had an awesome i met a fellow who's
running for uh fayetteville's mayor
fayetteville fort fayetteville fort
bragg in north carolina
and i had never thought about it this
like this and i've only had a few days
to even think about it but his proposal
was this and this guy is um
[Music]
an immigrant
he's puerto rican
um which you know part of the states but
not a state so still an immigrant
ray's poor
nine brothers and sisters right poor
family
anyway
he said hey man
what if
let's say
you've got a mother a single mother with
four children
all right
and some people say well she just keeps
having more children to get more welfare
okay maybe that's true in some
situations i don't think that's true
across the board i think in a lot of
cases these mothers have more and more
children
maybe they don't have access to birth
control maybe they're not super educated
on on just on sex education in general
right whatever that problem is we have
this person they're a reality right they
exist this family of the single mother
with these full children it exists they
exist
how do we help them how do we fix them
how do we get those four children to
grow up to become
productive involved u.s citizens that's
the question
well his answer was this let's say she's
getting
fourteen hundred dollars a month
um
from all the different programs total
that's about what she's getting fourteen
hundred
it's poverty bro
but if she gets a job she loses all of
it
if she gets a job that only pays her a
thousand dollars now she would be at
twenty four hundred dollars a month now
she's just barely getting by still she's
still in the poverty
but the second she takes a legal dollar
or something that's not under the table
she loses every cent of her welfare
funding how does that incentivize her or
her children to to go do something so
here was his plan and i was like huh
huh
he said let's lower it
let's take some welfare away i'm like i
wasn't expecting you to say that but
here's how i said it he said okay let's
knock it down let's cut that that 1400
to 600. she doesn't get a job she gets
she gets a job
and maybe she makes 500 a week
she gets
an additional 100 a week from welfare
so as she makes more she actually starts
getting more so let's say she goes from
that 1400 now she's making 2 000
uh in addition to her own like she's
making 2 000 a month at her job she's um
she's gone from that 500 or whatever
initial instead of the 1400 now she's at
a thousand
well there's a certain point in which
she makes enough money to actually pay
for her own welfare on tax dollars
it now pays for itself the incentive is
for
that lady that young woman to go work
harder
to make money and now she will actually
pay for her own welfare it's a zero-sum
game for american taxpayers
and i was like holy [__] i've never
heard that before i've never thought
about it like that before i always
thought about it like the more you make
the less you get from welfare right like
if you're making 1400 on welfare and now
you're making two grand you're only
gonna get seven he's like no no it's
capped right it's not like she just
keeps making now she's making 200 000 a
year she gets 50 000 in welfare right no
it's capped there's a point in which it
all goes away
and he even said he goes now maybe
there's actually a pyramid where it goes
up to a certain amount and as she
continues to make more it goes down a
little bit and then it's
ended but it's all based off of and he's
like it would take a lot of work
because everywhere in the nation the
cost of living is different
so
you would have to build it around all of
that he's like but it would work
and it would fix the whole
problem is that you would be addressing
the animosity
and the resentment that tax paying
hard-working americans have against
welfare recipients that stigma
right
that whole uh just cancer welfare type
well now the welfare recipient is paying
for its own welfare for their unwelfare
not it's right that's dehumanizing i
didn't mean to do that
but that person is now paying for their
own welfare i was like wow bro i'm like
you can't be the only person you're
you know this you know puerto
rican-american that's running for mayor
in fayetteville you mean to tell me the
only person that's ever thought of this
and probably not he's just the only
person that ever told me about it and i
was like i've just never thought about
it right it's never been in my entire
life have i ever i've never had to sit
down and start thinking about viable
ways to end the welfare state in america
it's not been a problem that i had to
address in my military career or my
small business right
you know
not a problem so now that i'm
running for house of representatives it
is something that i got to start looking
at and i was blown away so
again back to my point of
problems are never two plus two equals
four
also ain't that easy no it's never that
easy and when we have that conversation
and we sit back and say
hey man yeah this isn't working we need
to adjust just like man if we're in
route to a target
you briefed your platoon or i believe my
you know troop
and isr reports back oh no there's not
15 mofos on this target man they're
having some type of get together there's
40 muldoons on this target you know and
trucks and what appears to be some pkms
in those trucks we thought it was going
to be easy target on and off right nice
little fun tuesday night
i saw i was reporting something
different do we go
yeah roger that
click and hang up and we're not talking
about anymore i'm not even gonna brief
my my troopers no we probably come to a
little tactical hall huddle up and let's
discuss this if the key leaders are
going to sit down and chat
right
is this assault force even able to take
that target well probably not okay let's
head back to the house we made a mistake
right based off of information out we
didn't make a mistake based off of
information as it changed
let's just hit pause you know or maybe
we request more air and we first go on
up and we don't hit the target we let
the air force do it for us or or the
navy or the marines or whoever's flying
for us that night you know
it's so frustrating man because it's
like
you know there's
there's eight
sf guys running for for uh us house
representative there's seven seals
um
and like i said 25 30 global
volunteerism
veterans
you know somebody asked me the other day
well what sets you apart from these
other candidates we're all conservatives
we all pretty much agree on how you know
we all have the same stances on
everything
the difference between
the first difference between me and some
of my opponents is spine and shoulders
right and i don't mean that in a bad way
like i mean like because they're good
people right the folks i'm running
against
um sam's probably one of them are good
people good people who really want to go
change and if you ask them they're going
to capitol hill and they're going to
save the planet
here's reality the reality is a freshman
brand new representative in congress
has zero influence and no friends
lobbyists don't even knock on their
office door they got a little cubbyhole
and office over in that other building
they're nobodies
so
they look for friends
they make friends with lobbyists and
other little groups and caucuses right
and
the incumbents the three four five 20
term representatives
they recruit them
they do them favors now we got clicks
and this is politics and it's the
grossness of it
here's what aside from me not being
willing to compromise right i've said
straight up four terms if amer if
america or north carolina have district
13 or whatever whichever district i want
to run in four terms is all i will do
period we need term limits whether or
not we can get that pushed through or
not if when i'm up there
different story i'm still not going to
i'm going to self-impose my own term
limits i don't want to work in dc
and i was one of my opponents recently
told me i was a um
ignorant wannabe
and i was like yep
except for the differences i i was like
you're absolutely right i am pretty
ignorant exactly the kind of [__]
you guys are doing
in politics
but you're wrong about the wannabe part
not a wannabe i don't want to run for
connors but because of people like him
america needs
us to run
well i'm not willing to compromise
that's the biggest thing i'm not
you know i say this all the time right
i'm not even mad at democrats
i'm pissed off at republicans who have
compromised our rights away
they keep thinking somehow that they can
negotiate or not even negotiate because
i'll clarify the difference between
negotiate and compromise they keep
compromising with the the left and the
democrats thinking they're all going to
get along and come to some type of
agreement democrats just take just keep
taking that [__] putting it out back
piling it up
we got some more from them we got some
more from them republicans go well if we
keep playing nice with them
maybe one day they'll be our friends no
man the democrats are hell-bent on
creating a communist regime in this
country
they don't care what you think they
don't want to be your friend they want
to get rid of you
they want to replace you and we see this
playing out in this whole politics right
now right all of a sudden you keep
seeing everything like what's the what's
the cure for covet midterm elections
all of a sudden the mandates yeah the
science says no [__] and freaking
ain't no there's no there was no the
covenant numbers haven't changed at all
the science hasn't changed at all
midterms are coming
and democrats know they're about to lose
and across the country through boards of
elections and every different means they
can they're trying to protect their what
they have left and we see it in north
carolina with the redistricting and all
this nastiness
but anyway
the number two thing that sets me apart
is that group of veterans those green
berets those seals
when we show up let's say half of us
right let's say there's there's 30 it's
just over 30 global war on terrorism
veterans young
vibrant not old gray-haired crippled old
man easy on the gray hair bro
[Laughter]
you're not old you're still vibrant
you know
there's uh
i keep looking at it like this right
we're still young if most of the 20 year
old troopers the the 20 to 30 year old
troopers in the teams or on the odas
don't want a fist fighter
the second they know that we're we're
not able to you know hold our own then
we're that old line that gets pushed out
you know but i would say right now the
average 20 to 30 year old soft trooper
doesn't really want to throw down with
either one of us right i mean some of
them would they probably whip our old
asses we're gonna be sore the next day
no matter what but the difference is
they know we got this old
knowing we're either highly aggressive
violent
and smart right like you don't get
through 20-something years of war just
being lucky you know
and i always tell them that you know i'm
still in 20th group man i teach down
ourself out of course and i'll pick on
the youngins and i'll be like okay
whatever man you know that that fun
you know shooting [__] [__] talking
whatever you want to call it and i'm
like okay whatever man you want a fist
fight
on the outside i look like i'm ready
you know
ready to get after it on the inside i'm
like please look god don't let this do
this right don't let this kid freak out
i
actually want to take me up on this
offer because it's going to hurt so bad
but yeah man could you imagine
20. global world terrorism veterans
right
12 of them special operations guys
swearing oath for a second time on
capitol hill
the democrats shaking in their boots
because they know they just lost and the
republicans going
uh-oh
we're gonna have to ask those guys those
newbies these freshmens
we're gonna have to
really team up with these guys and work
with them
that's some stuff that could change
america's trajectory
and that's the difference between me and
some of my really good opponents good
people right i mean i got a guy that's
running in the district against me man
he's a good old boy good old country boy
we talked after meeting we hit it off
and i was like man any other time you
and i met we'd just be hunting fishing
buddies
he's a good carolina boy
and i told him i was like hey man
tell you what
don't you just let me and my buddies go
up there for a couple years i told you
i'm out this is not a career for me
i'll do everything in the world to help
you run after i'm done
you know of course he didn't take me up
on that off
he's still convinced he can beat me um
and and maybe he can but that's the cool
thing about democracy right i have to
show the people in this district that
i'm i'm the best candidate
um i can't just say i am i have to go
show them
and uh so anyway man it's uh
some interesting stuff not so much
it's like so simple
but it's not easy
yeah
uh
so
a little sidetrack right there
you get you get done with afghanistan
you go do some
stuff working with law enforcement what
not
and then
when do you end up going to iraq
um
just before the invasion
and
so iraq happens all that goes down i'm
up north
and
made more friends more current friends
more friends over at the uh the agency
and because we were basically doing that
uh advanced prep
for northern iraq with the kurds and
everything
so you got there before the invasion and
you're up with the kurds yeah and you're
prepping for
what's going on the war's coming right
yeah so you know evasion goes down
freaking i was running around like mosul
kirkuk crit all that stuff
um
are you with us
oda team i'm actually with one of the um
with one of the sad teams okay because
i'm that young kid that doesn't look
like an sf guy right so
really cool um
yeah
iraq happens
and then
in my next trip to afghanistan
i got bumped off a cliff and i broke my
back how'd you get bumped off a cliff
one of our partners tripped
we were walking down
and he was above me and he tripped
80 90 pound backpack
you know nice
you know
freaking offset infill
yeah thought
how far how high was the cliff
probably fell 15 feet
you know enough to you know and
basically
when when he hit me you know i kind of
like feet went out and landed basically
on my ass like my feet were kind of out
in front of me a little outcropping and
it that rucksack just buckled me right
it just
split my uh l5 how much did you weigh at
this point
were you jacked yet cause yeah i'm
starting i'm starting to put on some
people talking about this yeah
now we're you know three years into the
end of the war four years into the war
man i've been hitting the weight pile
like everybody else i'm probably like a
buck 85 and um
yeah man it just bent me over split my
vertebrae part of the vertebrae hit my
spinal cord
the prognosis was you might walk with
crutches one day
so were you like paralyzed on sight bro
that whole i can't feel my legs yeah i
didn't experience that because i could
feel it and it hurt like hell right if
you took this dude put it in a fire got
it nice and orange and stuck it in the
side of my spine back here that's what
it felt like
all the way to my toes
it was it was like i was on fire did
they cast a vacuum oh yeah um
spent
three or four months in a brace doing
the wheelchair thing freaking uh got
better
uh
really fast
so within a year i'm running again well
my ets date came up and i had a flight
packing in
i wanted to be a pilot
i thought you know my ground pounding
days was i had already done everything
we could right how many more countries
are we invading no i thought my ground
pounding days was over and these apache
gun ships keep flying in and just doing
all our work i'm like
i mean great air conditioning yeah
yeah they got like they could only work
a few hours a day i'm like man these
these warrant officers they can fly for
the rest of their lives you know because
the army has a warrant officer program
so i put in a packet all i had to do was
get home and go to flight school it's
going to be awesome
well that clearly changed i thought my
career was over
so luckily those friends that i made at
the agency i got out and i initially did
you get medically retired or
young and dumb man
my intent i thought i was gonna go
contract for a little while get better
and then i would come back in the army
and fly
just take some time off and there's all
these awesome contracting jobs out here
they're paying awesome oh and this is
because you're the national guard so you
could say hey i i'm non-deployable for a
while right i'm going to heal up yeah
but you'd still be in the national guard
but i got a contract
because at this point the guard has
figured out that they're
just hemorrhaging dudes to contracting
so you got all these uh battalion
commanders
so 0405 oh yeah this is like 1500 bucks
a day yeah for contractors and stuff
shutting it down and they're like nope
you know you still got to be at your
drills you still got to meet your
commitments whereas in like 0.203 you
had company commanders jumping in and
they were like yeah i don't care if
y'all show up or not and if you think
about it right like you've got your
troopers overseas doing you know at
least combat ish type stuff
you know
it was a good thing for the guard
you had guard guys that were getting
exponentially more combat experience
through contracting
than the active duty groups were doing
because they were just rotating you know
so it was a good thing for the guard but
it wasn't good for their numbers right
it didn't look good they had guys that
weren't getting their
online training done you know
right like you got to do your eo and
your sharp string right it was killing
those numbers for these commanders
so they shut it down so i was like screw
it i'm out
i'll just come back in you know i'll go
make some money whatever buy a house or
something which is you know exactly what
i did but
as i got better you know i went became
operational again and started doing cool
stuff way cooler than the army ever was
gonna let me do
this is as a contractor yeah
so i never went back in or i didn't go
back into fly
um
and at one point it was kind of funny
because i did go back in and join 20th
group in like 2012 which i'm i'm still
in
how long so but that's a pretty big gap
though you got like seven almost eight
years seven eight years now and were you
contracting the whole time whole time
non-stop
i stayed really busy with that of course
i started the gym i would come home i
got lucky man you know teamwork right
what makes a dream work when i started
my gym which i opened it in january of
2008.
that that's when this gym opened yeah
yeah yeah very cool
right
you know 2008 i was going nine months
i opened a gym
luckily the the team that i put in place
ran it like it was their own
they did an amazing job amazing job good
friend of mine darren canceler man he
just did it uh the young lady i was
dating at the time julie they
they ran the damn thing and and so i
could come home and be the war hero that
showed up to run the gym and take over
for a minute and ruin their lives you
know they had to play anyway they did
things nope i'm gonna do it my way you
know like no hopefully i wouldn't like
that but uh you know intrinsically
that'll happen but they just did an
awesome job with my gym
and i could i could i could stay
deployed and i did
and um the gym grew so that was cool it
was kind of a parallel there and um
the gym was great you know it was
supposed to be just a little crossfit
gym that you know guys like us marine
recon boys and marshock dudes because
we're just south of lejeune come in
there take their shirts off spit on the
floor throw up if they want to
and we'll just thrash ourselves and then
regular people started showing up right
like soccer moms and stuff and you know
i'm still at this point in my life i'm
like
hey you you know you you know stop being
a puss and and you know maybe stop
eating so many doughnuts fatso and you
could dagon be a pt stud too
well
when
a 33 year old 36 year old mother of two
or three that drives a suburban pulls up
you can't talk to her like that because
she won't come back
and those are also the people that have
the money to pay their gym memberships
those college kids that are studs that
you want to train they ain't got no
money right you gotta at least pay the
light bill um so i quickly figured out
how to talk to regular people you know
you can't be like hey sally
maybe cut out that bottle of wine and
that box of donuts every night you might
be able to do a pull-up
yeah she's never got any
i was real adamant about not being that
uh creepy gym owner and you know who was
like
you know um having any type of
fraternization with clients and stuff
like that was a big deal and i did start
that gym with a partner and it quickly
figured out it wasn't going to work um
not a bad separation there just like he
couldn't move to wilmington
and um but yeah man it was that jim
taught me a lot about teaching
you know just how to talk to people you
couldn't hey ranger you know
hey sally come here what's going on you
know you um hey when you're ready if
you'd like um let's sit down and maybe
line out some nutrition diets and stuff
you know nutrition not diet right those
words mean something because if you say
something to a lady who needs to drop 20
pounds
you know if you say hey let's talk about
getting you on a diet oh my god bro you
just she's gone she hates your guts but
if you're like hey look let's tune this
up and go man your shoulders are
starting to get really defined you're
looking great and that was a cool thing
about crossfit right is that when his
upper body started to develop
and you know you clearly can't be that
creep and talk to her about her legs or
any other you know lady parts or
whatever you know
you can't be like hey sally you know
your bum is looking great that's that's
inappropriate right it's not
professional
and uh so
i really learned how to to talk to
people and then motivate them and bring
them into the fold
and you know before we know it that was
one thing my gem was so well known for
i'm so proud of it is that are women
monsters
and i mean people would come to me like
other gym owners and stuff like what are
you doing
to motivate and turn these
women into these these
monsters right we sent like uh i don't
know um 18 different athletes through
the crossfit games
out of a
a town of only 150 000 people damn
and it was just i didn't even have to
recruit once it started we had one of
the original super strong females she
just showed up she was a volleyball
player powerful right she could
very coordinated to her and only lift
him before you knew it she was like
throwing weight over her head that most
of the dudes in the gym couldn't touch
and um so people started hearing about
her and then it grew and then
her and then a handful of others and
next thing you know i've got these
i'm looking for dudes
our thing was the team events i love the
team events i don't know the individuals
is cool right and a whole different
level but the team was fun and i'm all
about building a team
so our teams did really well
but there were years where
[Music]
you know a couple years where we didn't
the team didn't go to the games
because the guys on my team weren't
strong enough to get us
on the podium at regionals it was never
the girls man um
i trained one young lady she came in the
gym of fino right like just this diamond
in a rough
fast twitch powerful she'd been a soccer
player a swimmer at ecu
god bless her heart she's just
imagine the most hard-headed ranger
young seal pup you ever dealt with this
was her man but like the first time she
ever deadlifted she picked up over 300
pounds i walked in was like stop stop
stop what are you doing who is she why
is she picking up that kind of weight
she's clearly new
right horrible farm which is powerful
so anyway that's impressive she quite
she she could have been an individual
athlete she had that type of genetics um
she went a different route that year i
couldn't put her on my team she just
wasn't ready yet she couldn't work with
the team she came in a little late she
had everything going for i was like hey
in the interim um let's play with strong
man
right we just started getting strong man
equipment it was getting more and more
worked into the crossfit stuff and we
kind of did a pure thing and some of the
gym members you know i was that guy who
was i was like the most anti-crossfit
crossfit gym owner on the planet i was
like crossfit was supposed to be to get
you in shape so you can go do cool stuff
you want to try a triathlon you want to
try you know you want to
whatever you know um i never really saw
crossfit as like becoming a sport but i
can't help it i like to compete you know
let's get in it um so anyway this young
lady kimberly lawrence
she i said hey let's try strongman
so she did like a local event crushed it
this chick was and still is super strong
well that event qualified her for the
worlds at the arnold's damn
she weighed 165 pounds naturally she
never touched any drugs
and strongman is not a tested sport
right
so the middleweight class and the
females are the is the most competitive
and it's 140 180 pounds and most of the
girls cut from 200
there's you know 5 eleven six foot tall
two hundred pound females
and like i said not tested
kimberly goes to the arnold bro
and wins world her second strong man
competition wins it and she didn't cut
she walked on walked into the
competition 165 pounds this is what she
weighed at the time right i mean she's
you know probably
five
nine five eight or nine
just naturally emotional well not
naturally she had been an athlete in
college right but just exploding you
said she swam and played volleyball
and soccer okay just aggressive too man
just like hostile
that
she should
at the time there wasn't a good mma
presence in wilmington that's that's
where she should have gone
that's where she should have gone uh as
one of the gems um salter and those guys
stood up mmj uh mma gym there and had
that been stood up out of center over
there
i mean go kill people with a little bit
of training this chick would have been
scary right she was and she would go
over there and train and play and she
went through a little phase where she
was doing some striking and stuff and i
was just like
god man
anyway long story short with her she
kind of got involved in the wrong people
and stuff and um i didn't coach her
anymore freaking but what an amazing
chica and like i said man it was just so
cool that our females were so well known
when like every lady on the team is
snatching 200 pounds deadlifting three
plus like kimberly was deadlifting 500
pounds at a buck 70 and had abs you know
what i mean she did not look like a
power lifter and this is just the ladies
we had they were just badass you know
melissa went to the games
um
she was just the small one she was the
bodyweight one
um and as crossfit
matured now the average crossfit female
is like a buck 65 man those are those
girls are big so melissa she can't
compete with them she can't move the
weight that they do
but yeah man the ladies and melissa was
instrumental in helping at once melissa
realized she wasn't big enough because
last time we went to the games
you know dawn was you know
probably at the time 160 165 a girl
amanda 150 pounds another volleyball
player
um
and um jordan
probably 150 pounds and every single one
of them were instead left him 400 pounds
cleaning jerking over two i mean these
these chicks and running sub six minute
miles
like what the
and i mean you know luckily that last
year the boys were all big boys and
studs but
melissa was you know an amazing amazing
coach to those ladies she's once you
know the deal once you realize you ain't
you ain't ever going to be in the ring
again right like you can either
you know what is it those who can't do
teach
and that's just reality same for me
right like as i got older i was like i
don't stand a chance of being you know
involved in this sport but i can damage
or coach some people to it but yeah the
gym was amazing man freaking
it was lucky that i could run it in a
parallel once me and melissa started
dating i started i went through a phase
where i didn't deploy a whole lot
like teaching stuff stateside
and uh a highway patrol friend of mine
asked me to start helping uh him like
teach some firearms
uh his father had a nice range and stuff
i'm like yeah man why not you know
he was going through a divorce and
needed some money um
so i was like yeah you know he's like
yeah i think you know with your
background you know we can we can bring
in some people and that's how this the
whole
shooting part of my business kind of
started was just trying to help a buddy
that needed some you know money because
he was going through a divorce and um
so that turned out i mean i
i just don't know how to do anything
half-ass right if i'm gonna do something
i'm doing it you know
that's why i like all the physical stuff
the triathlons the ultra marathons hell
i put myself in the hospital after the
bigfoot 200. not after
because i didn't quite finish
my 177 i'm pissing blood wrapped in my
laces freaking i was in bad badges how
many hours into it was that
probably 70 some day three
yeah um
you're uh familiar with the company uh
softly
yeah those guys yeah so bran i don't
know them but i know who they are yeah
so uh brent one of the the founders and
owners uh marshak dude good friend of
mine
he joined me at mile 112 of that race
and i was already in bad shape uh from
like a section of the race it was a lot
of downhill
well first we don't have mountains where
i live in north carolina so i trained
uphill on a stair mill dude i would go
to the gym and spend four and five hours
walking on a stair mill
miserable
miserable stupid
but i set a goal you like running at
this at this point in my life i don't
like running anymore right i decided i'm
going to run a 200 mile race why to say
i did
well yeah man that race
one of the sections about 11 miles all
downhill and i ran the [__] out of it
and your muscles weren't used to that
quads destroyed them
destroyed them at mile 112 i was already
pissing blood and that's from
yeah
my kidneys were hurting i could feel it
felt like somebody just worked on my
freaking back man
and um
about my 150 something at that aid
station that was the last time i could
even keep water down i was
my tbi was definitely flared up i had a
lot of damage to my brainstem and stuff
when i got blown up in 2009 and
yeah man i um
[Music]
i was in bad shape and i wanted to sleep
he wouldn't let me sleep come to find
out later he was like yeah i was worried
you were going to die because i was
having a seizure
and i was laughing about it
you know i had convinced myself you know
you know the deal man you know how we
we can be
and i just took it too far at
by about 177 man i'd gone you know on
almost an entire night 20 some miles
without any food or water no sleep just
you know brent was just trying to get me
to the next uh
aid station because it's in the
mountains of washington state around i
would say helens they have no evac plan
there's no way
and i'm probably the biggest runner on
the course right i'm doing these 200
mile race at like 215 pounds you know
and i had lost weight to do it
you know i think i usually walk around
about you know 225 230ish or whatever
and i cut some weight to go run this
race
and how many months did you prepare for
it
like a year year and a half
the so we trained for about half a year
for the 2007
bigfoot
melissa tore her meniscus at like mile
and so we we stopped at mount 133 we
were doing it together
and i had time but
during
during that last trek i didn't want to
leave her it was cold way colder than it
was supposed to be so we didn't i mean
teeth chattering we were both
hypothermic and
she's busted her knee can't move fast
and so at like mile 132 or three that
aid station
we got there in time and i could have
taken off with no rest or whatever and
got to the next one but i probably
wouldn't have finished a race right i
was just now i was behind
and i would have never left her on that
mountain right like
especially hypothermia you know she's
she's never had hypothermia to where she
was
you know
freaking disoriented or something like
that and and you know
just
clearly i wouldn't have left
a runner i didn't know in her shape much
less i'm not leaving the most precious
thing on this planet to me
so we got to that station i'm like you
know what screw it honey we started it
together let's go get some breakfast
together you know someone's coming up so
we drove back to portland had some
breakfast the next year
she decided to do it but we made a deal
that we wouldn't do it together no
no preconceived notions her knee was
still not healthy she's like i'll try it
i mean that says a lot about her man
she's like i got this energy i'm gonna
give it a whirl she did like 77 miles
and dropped
only 77 on a busted knee
she's she's probably worse than us but
um
yeah man at mile 1
176 177 whatever it was
brent was like hey man i'm gonna run
ahead
and uh
make sure the crew is ready no he was
running ahead to make sure the medics
and the doctors were there so they could
drop my ass
205 miles man you know so i had you know
whatever it was 29 miles or something
left
and i get there and they're like
yeah here's the drop paperwork i'm like
i'm not signing that
i'm twitching having seizures my trachea
is freaking like
not working correctly you know my so
some of my damage and stuff i used to be
left-handed i'm right-handed now because
this didn't work for a while right like
i couldn't hold on to things i
definitely but worse i would have a
seizure
well if you're holding a glock and your
hand seizes probably not a good thing so
i switched to being right-handed all
that was happening i'm like seizing and
it's a it's not a muscular seizure it's
a cns seizure and it's just weird it
doesn't hurt but when it happens it
looks weird
looking good at this point and bro
the pictures of me i'm gray
right that whole dehydrated my body
temperature was 96.4 degrees and my
heart resting heart rate was like a buck
60. oh laying down on a cot you know
when you lay down your heart rate should
drop your mind didn't
my body's freaking out and i'm convinced
i don't know it's only 29 miles i got
this
and luckily
luckily one of those five people i chose
i'm kind of scared of was helping me
and he was like hey bubba
you can either get your ass in that
truck i'ma put your ass in there
either way you are done with this race
the next thing i remember i woke up in
the in the hospital in portland oregon
how long was the recovery from that
yeah that's a that's a more fun story um
three weeks after that
on the last day to register for the moab
240 miler i went and got my blood work
done 88 kidney function i'm like all
right i'm good and i signed up for the
moab 240 and how far away was that at
the time
as far as like how much time did you
have before that
two weeks oh it was only two weeks away
last day to register for the moab and
here's my thought process oh i gotta
hear this
because it hurt man rhabdo hurt a lot
more i'd heard of rabdo right you know
crossfit made it famous everybody you
knew what rhabdo was i knew you know but
we all give ourselves micro cases of it
and then we take days off the reason
there's no days off in a four day 200
mile race you don't get to recover you
know it gets worse
well
three weeks after i go in i'm like okay
i'm trying to figure out do i train
another year because this is the first
thing in my life i've dnf'd
first thing i've ever did not finish you
know man i've been like first time goes
and every hard course they ever sent me
to you know like this isn't this isn't
making sense to me
voluntarily withdrawing the year before
because melissa was hurt i was okay with
that like it didn't hurt my feelings you
know i didn't feel like i had
somehow compromised you know my soul
your integrity is a man now but now the
bigfoot all right they almost tried to
kill me and i'm like okay there's this
moab 240 it's all ran by the same people
i'm like this no i have 240 mile race
it's actually 243 miles just like the
bigfoot 200 is 205 i'm like y'all need
to fix your t-shirts because last time i
checked a five miler that's like a race
internet so give me credit i want credit
so the the moab 240 243 miles
in my head was okay do i train a whole
another year and when you train for a
200 are you talking about going out at
midnight and train until six in the
morning just to get training under your
headlamps and stuff like that it's
miserable dude at this point in my life
i'm not a runner anymore and i don't
enjoy training it i
[__] since then i think i've ran about
six miles and that was 2018 right it's
all been like three different army pt
tests i had to take you know
um yeah i ride my bicycle now my
mountain bike and stuff but anyway
yeah man i'm like okay i can train a
whole another year or maybe i can knock
out this 240 and just check this box and
say i did at 200 right it's 240 it
should be good
make up for this disaster silliness of
the bigfoot
last day of registering i was down in
alabama teaching 20 groups of falcors i
drove to one of those local
blood work places had my labs pulled
interpreted myself pretty much qualified
for that
um because you're going to be an 18 year
old at one point so you're good to go
close man i've done some nutrition
counseling for people at the gym right i
can yeah creating teenage levels are
almost back to normal almost
right i'm like all right
walked out of the parking lot
signed up for the 240.
clearly i know it's not a good idea
because i didn't tell anyone until a
couple days before already had an 18
delta mine that was gonna
you know crew me at the race and that
just basically means drive the truck
from one aid station to the next and the
truck is a place to sleep
and um so yeah man i got the moab 240.
so i always say that you know dumb dumb
ranger tony did
bigfoot where i was like i'll sleep an
hour a night and i'll just keep moving
and i'll keep banking extra hours
well the
moab 240 just approached completely
different i'm asleep two hours to three
hours every night and i'm gonna use
every second of time to make it from
here to here
i was trying to bank time and go fast
now you build up this extra time
would you know how many people remember
my finish time of that moab 240
zero
i don't even remember what it was all i
know is i finished it and i got a
picture of me walking underneath a
finish line right and i do know i did
have about six hours to spare six to
eight hours of spare whatever it was
but the point here is unlike the bigfoot
where i was trying to go so hard and not
sleep i walked every step of the way at
last except for the last 13 miles of 243
miles i rucked it
you know and you're just wearing one of
them silly little vests you know it's
like maybe 10 pounds enough to get you
you know in between eight stations which
you know are they're pretty considerable
i mean you're talking about an a-station
a station 20-25 miles you know like
marathons it's not like a marathon where
there's a station every mile
this is the middle of nowhere nowhere
moab you know
so yeah man knocked that crazy [__] out
and uh
freaking
um
we heck i was so fresh and and okay that
hopped in the truck instead of staying
in moab drove back to denver
you know and um so yeah man freaking
good experience
don't necessarily recommend it to anyone
but if you do get a wild hair and want
to run at one of those races give me a
ring or a dm and i'll i'll tell you my
strategy my strategy was rook march the
whole way the only reason i even ran the
last 13-ish and we didn't run the whole
way is that i linked up with a dude that
i had met at the the bigfoot and we
checked it in
um
and uh but i wouldn't say that we ran
that whole 13. we just i picked up the
pace did some jogging blah blah
but yeah man um
you know
like i said just got to get after it you
know and purpose you know like we talked
about that whole having something
i don't know if you get dramatic say
having something to live for but that's
ultimately what it is
and um yeah i stay busy these days
i'm over the craziness
these days my pt is all about just
staying healthy so i can go hunting you
know
that's it i just that's my only real
hobby i have left
as long as i'm fit enough to throw a 60
pound backpack on and go hike around the
mountains and
you know um
that's where i'm at in life i'm i'm done
you know melissa's
still getting after it just crushing
herself in the gym i'm in there like i
think i'll do back and buy maybe maybe
maybe just you know chest and tries
today you know and then a nice little
light leg day like my deadlifts man so i
just turned 46 and i was like all right
you know for fun
let's put some weight on there
500 for three on a deadlift i'm like
still not old yet you know what i mean
i'm still kind of young but typically
speaking man 400 on the deadlifts all i
do and just do some reps i'm not trying
to hurt me anymore
because through a lot of the stuff that
i did man my back hurt my
you know tbi hurt
always on that edge and where'd you get
blown up in iraq
yeah um
freaking armored sedan ied meant for a
striker
yeah sucks man i was the only one of
four in the vehicle to walk away and i
didn't walk away
um
yeah um
suck man freaking we just happened we
were we were the mark car
for the ranger regiment they were
they were going to action a big target
for us uh where was it iraq
mosul
and so we basically we were going to
identify
we were going to identify the gate that
they were going to drive the strikers
through just by simply pulling just past
it and parking at that point by the time
they got there i would already be out of
the vehicle
last thing i remember is buckling my
helmet
putting the buckle on i just put my
helmet on
and uh so yeah it was an um you know it
was a level 7 bmw but
it's you know they're bulletproof's not
blastproof not definitely not efp proof
efp
hit um
right behind the rear seat so the two
boys in the back seat man they were
dna'd and uh driver i guess he he died
you know eight or ten hours afterwards
the um a funny story man like you know
talk about small world stuff a few years
later
i'm running one of the um training
courses for the nsa for them for their
security guys participating in that
and it was into the class everybody got
picked and this one young ranger or
whatever you know throughout the class
we talked about yeah i worked for these
people i was in mosul blah blah
you know because he's a student he
didn't ask until afterwards you know
everybody graduated let's go get a you
know steak and some beer and he's like
hey uh hey tony um
did you know that that team of guys the
agency team of guys or whatever um up in
in mosul that you know they got blown up
the whole team died
i was like
um
i mean 2009
and he's like yeah yeah yeah we were up
there man we were i was in the range
raiser and we helped recover that
we were
on target for that we were going to do
that
when they threw me in their strikers
they thought i was dead
because the reality is right man it blew
that car across
three lanes it was a main highway one
called it broadway
we were in the right lane about to make
a right turn into the neighborhood where
the target was hence why i just buckled
my helmet
and uh that efp blew that car
all the way across three lanes big
medians you know the medians are there
and stuff right across that across three
lanes and down the alleyway
yeah
hitting other cars right it wasn't a
small id and how i live man i can only
talk that one up to god you know
and um man it hurt
the blast injuries hurt i came to in
germany and it
hurt everything hurt man like i'd say
like my fingernails hurt
my gut splash gut my lungs i had a demon
in my lungs
and you know that armored car probably
you know clearly saved me blah blah blah
but yeah man my whole left side was
screwed up freaking just from damage to
that brainstem and all that stuff and
yeah and that was why you were a
contractor
because you ended up going back in right
yeah i am
i what 2012 i was like you know what you
know freaking i did these you know this
eight years
maybe i should go back into guard i
could help the next generation right you
know
what's that thing about good intentions
i say that if you get out of the
military and then go back in the
military it's like taking your car
driving it into a parking deck
putting in it reverse and then backing
over the spikes and blowing your tires
on purpose
that's what going back in the military
is like
and i joke i i do joke right so
the uh
i'll try and keep that in mind because
you know all the time i you know those
mornings when i wake up like you know i
can probably you know
call some people
rock and roll
no i um i i
went
and so i work for asd advanced skills
attachment the group level asd so i get
to teach the courses like our cqb course
falc and it is worth it but the guard
has its own beast right there's like all
the bs that you would put up with with
the
active duty military and then there's
the guard it has its own personality its
own type of crap
and because it is a part-time thing for
so many people and the few full times
that they full-timers that they have
they're trying to manage you know on
half staff all these guys
who all have problems who are all the
most important people in their own lives
blah blah
luckily i have an amazing admin staff
where i work and stuff and they keep it
squared away
but you know it's still the military
and because we're not full time we have
to jump out of our asses
to do stuff you know the budget blah
blah hell
alabama national guard sent a bunch of
people
to d.c after the january 16th the
federal government has still not paid
alabama back
for that
right
and that's across the board there are
national guards across our country that
don't have funding to pay people so like
some of our full-time guys in october
when the fiscal year rolled around last
fall lost their jobs
for like three weeks
it's like what
um and these are people with mortgages
and families and stuff you know it's
their job like oh no we don't have money
because you know joe biden don't want to
you know send us money
right of course you don't
actually who
signs the budgets
congress
so is it joe biden's fault
or is it
our representative's fault
i don't know i mean i always go back to
this right first page
ranger handbook the leader is
responsible for everything that does and
does not happen on a mission or patrol
so anyway um i digress but yeah the
guard man it's good i get interact with
the young guys only the up and comers
share some um
lessons learned
and uh
it's worth it but
you know
if i go teach stuff out for four weeks
i'm back to making army money so you
know you lose money doing it
and sometimes you ask is it worth it
i gotta go put up with this bs and
you know whatever um but then i remember
like hey man
we now have a service full of all the
combat vets got out
there's no combat veterans left in
special forces for the most part right
same with the seals man i got some guys
from virginia beach that come down and
use my long range
all young young pups and they're snipers
i'm like i thought snipers were supposed
to be like the most experienced dudes
they're like
we are
like aren't you like 22
you're like 26. like so you mean to tell
me you are one of the most experienced
dudes in your platoon
when you're in the team
you're not 30 yet like yeah man everyone
with any experience left
i'm like well crap it's the same in the
army same in the marine corps
so i look like this man i feel a little
obligated to give back you know for
whatever reason i am still here with all
my fingers and toes i still can shoot i
still can teach and um
man i get down there i can't help it i'm
not the dude on the catwalk that's not
how i teach
i put my kid on and go and and do cqb
with the teams and i'm like all right
check it out guys and you're doing that
as an act as a guard guy yeah and you
when did you go back in the guard 2012
did you go on any deployments once you
hit 2012. i have it not with them got it
yeah that's that doesn't pay good enough
i mean you know if you so i weigh it out
like this
um since i've blown the asd we're not a
deploying unit anyway we're training
detached
um
to go do an eight month deployment with
sf
the return on investment just isn't
there for me it doesn't pay well enough
it's too long
whereas i can do stuff you know with the
agency and projects and stuff like that
that are shorter
and we actually get to do so you've
still been contracting the whole time
did you go to
syria who are you with over there with
your contractor yeah
what was that like
hm i mean
it's cool because like i said we're
not that would be the wrong i was going
to say our roes are different the roes
aren't different we have
a much more efficient chain of command
um i don't have to ask for permission to
you know
take a potty break
whereas you know
teams typically to move from here to
here have to ask permission we are given
a mission we're allowed to go execute
we send up sit reps we don't have to ask
for permission most of the time you know
you know we always have our marketing
there's something
yeah you know it's not for free for all
but we get a mission we go do it
a lot of our stuff is you know um
you know the aso type stuff the source
operations and then
afo you know doing the reconnaissance
and and um especially with with the
delay of the the ground as far as the
local population and a lot of promesi
type stuff
um and you you told me not to do that
here i am with an acronym right freaking
um prometheus like that that
area study of of all the equations that
make up a
an area whether it's you know population
resources and all that sort of thing not
not just like combatives right the
entire area what's going on in this area
so we do a lot of that um and of course
we can we need action targets if we need
to typically like in syria since we were
working in such small elements that you
know it was like
hey
ranger's not doing anything tonight you
know you know we got is there an oda
around here that can come do this you
know where the seals at you know
but um
yeah man that that that type of work is
really cool i've done stuff in haiti and
you know we've got a lot of things going
on that are
i said more more us interest than
national defense
and one definitely leads to the other
right like it's important if you talk to
a lot of people like oh we need to
withdraw from around the world
well if we want to continue to be a
superpower we have to continue to
influence in a positive way around the
world
this is why ukraine is so hard to figure
out right now
my take on ukraine is hey man
europe is full of a bunch of really
well-powered
modern
nations
it is their ao
right yeah with modern militaries very
modern militaries right we we help with
that
russia wants
russian
land back
the parts of the ukrainian really wants
i don't and maybe maybe putin i don't
know what putin's thinking right like
maybe he wants the whole nation but
they've shown us since you know even for
since 14 when they took or
they didn't take crimea right crimea
allowed themselves to be annexed there's
a big difference
the ukraine
you know the south and east i mean
they're native russians
right and that's again americans we're
too stupid to know that there is a
difference between
russians and ukrainians they speak two
different languages
right and do they a lot of them speak
both of course
you know it'd be no different than like
the border of texas lots of people spoke
speak both but there is a clear
difference between americans and
mexicans right and that's what's
happening here
in the ukraine nate russia wants it
lands back does russia also want a warm
water port well yeah russia has wanted a
warm water port for decades a century or
more now probably longer than that since
navies have been navies they've wanted
warm water
well
okay i get it are we at a point in our
so we have two things right like this
president who is weak clearly
could
stand up to russia draw a line in the
sand and be the heroes and russia
doesn't get to invade
or we can act tough
russia invades we look like a bunch of
[__]
and now we're obligated to fight that's
the wrong answer man
american
boys and girls don't need to go [__]
die in new ukraine
the ukraine is one of the most corrupt
nations on this planet now
that is partly due to russia keeping
them that way
a corrupt ukraine can't get into nato
all right nato's not letting them in in
their current state it's just not
happening so that's part of it is like
oh we want them in nato well if we
really wanted them in nato we'd let them
join nato three five ten years ago
they're not eligible
so
i mean come on man we gotta
you know like
there's a difference in messing and
meddling and getting ourselves into it
and you gotta you know again not a
conspiracy theorist but with everything
that's going wrong for
this administration one can't help but
to
at least entertain the idea that it's a
distraction
from all the other crappy mistakes now
all of a sudden biden wants to look
strong
well
there's biden and there's putin and i
don't think putin is ready to step back
from biden i think he's calling his
bluff man
you know and i don't think that the
biden has that hey let's sit down and
hash this out type of freaking mentality
you know well unfortunately in that
case like i
unfortunately
truthfully i have a hard time thinking
that that biden could carry on a logical
conversation and negotiation with putin
like it just doesn't seem like that's a
feasible thing i mean he has a hard time
he has a hard time unfortunately as we
watch him he has a hard time putting
together sentences right i mean putting
together legitimate sentences that are
prepped for him right that's just
reading really really disturbing really
really horrible to see and you think
he's going to go in with a freaking kgb
agent and
and be able to carry on a conversation
and not get manipulated and take taken
advantage of it's very disturbing a kgb
agent that for the last 20 years has not
been distracted by some wars
in the middle east and we have been he's
been preparing and preparing for
whatever he wants to do while we've been
messing about in the middle east yeah
and that that's you know talking earlier
about iterative decision making here's
another bad move when you're in a
leadership position is painting yourself
into a corner right you know don't paint
yourself in the corner the world changes
things change right things happen and
don't put yourself in a situation where
you can't say hey this is the direction
we're going now it's a little bit
different than we were heading but it's
okay because i the whole time was saying
i might go in a different direction
that's okay and you know what let's say
we have this amazing charismatic badass
leader which we don't that allows us to
look like we're letting russia pay us
into a quarter and improve he's got a
whole nother plan that would be cool but
that's not what's happening that's not
what happened right like that's that old
what's the uh everybody likes to quote
the whole um you know um what's the
chinese book uh sun tzu yeah right um i
always laugh i'm like whenever somebody
wants to uh you know sound like and
understand war they're going to quote
that guy you know feudal chinese battle
and
you know war theory
okay cool but
great some of us have actually
participated in war thanks for quoting
that um but there is a good the whole
thing of you know the ruse appear weak
when you're strong you know appear
strong when you're weak right like
always give missed signals to your um
to your enemy and adversaries
yeah that's not what we're doing our
adversary is clearly understand that we
have
a very broken leader i don't even want
to say lee
weak
because i would say that probably a
biden as goofball as he has been
throughout his career
you know biden in the 80s and 90s was a
a
definitely
an intelligent person right
um
that guy as a president probably
could have been decisive but despite we
have today it's just an an old broken
person um
and any of that you know i talk about
term limits
how about a retirement age
that we're not at this point yeah i mean
we have 80 plus year olds running our
country and i always ask people yeah
would you trust your 85 year old grandma
to walk your dog
right like put that into perspective
what would you trust your 85 year old
your 80 year old grandparents with and
i'm sure there are plenty of outliers
right there are 100 years old out there
that
are brilliant
outliers never prove a rule
military's retirement as a retirement
age every industry has a retirement age
our government 65
why are
our justices why are our representatives
why is our president allowed
what i mean
it's socially acceptable to have a
retirement age on these things
you know and of course dark moments but
it it
it scares me that we are literally at a
point right now where this this
president and this administration could
lead us into a world war and we're not
ready for it i mean i'm sure don't get
me wrong i mean how many weeks would it
take for american soldiers and sailors
to get ready yeah the military is ready
for it the military's ready technically
to fight of course right but
are we ready to
start losing people in ukraine which a
lot of people couldn't even figure out
where it is on a map that we don't
understand we don't care about that much
against russia who's russia so
who's ready for that when you say who's
ready
i'd say we're ready to fight of course
but are we ready to go and die
and kill a bunch of people that we don't
know and civilians that are going to die
as well it's like
we may want to think through that a
little bit i'm all for helping our
allies
right that's a good thing we need a
strong bunch of allies
but the ukraine has known for
well over a decade right
that putin wanted that land back
so my question is what has the ukraine
what has ukraine i've been told that
you're not supposed to call it the
ukraine yeah do you know why because
ukraine i guess it means
frontier and if you say the frontier
which is the ukraine that's the frontier
of russia
so calling it the frontier that's that's
really happening okay that's where that
is
from somebody told me like in a comment
on social media that it's not the
ukraine it's just ukraine okay sorry i
don't know that i'm not purposely trying
to diminish that nation uh no intent
implied um
yeah i don't know jacob man it's it's
it's so frustrating it's like we have
all these problems and i again i'm not
the i'm not the guy that says hey we
have to completely withdraw from the
rest of the world now we we have to be
involved yeah that's not to maintain our
status
but like to just to go meddle with the
ukraine when they've done very little to
prepare themselves for this date which
they knew was coming
they've done nothing to
get their
allies in europe to help them they've
you know like
hey
and again any of these situations any of
these situations around the world just
to say oh we're not going to get
involved with any anyone anymore that's
not a good move no that's not that's not
a good move
it's a good move to say well okay what's
happening what would make sense let's
try this approach let's see what happens
with this approach if this approach
works cool we'll continue to invest in
that approach if that approach isn't
working we'll say you know what we
didn't realize that there's a bunch of
different because ukraine's got all
kinds of different factions in there oh
we didn't realize that we we we looked
at it a little bit too broad and we
thought ukraine was ukraine it was
ukraine against russia doesn't really
look like it's that anymore uh we're
gonna stand down right or we're gonna
back away or we're gonna really support
this group that we know is now come to
the surface as being the the prominent
power there okay
instead of saying what we're saying
right now like we don't understand
what's happening fully and we can't
predict the future so don't
don't over index on things that you
can't predict don't do that in anything
right
well and also let's influence clearly we
are still
a superpower with tons of influence
even if
our european allies don't respect our
current leader he still brings to the
table an immense
amount of
tools that he can use to sway them hey
look oh hey britain
you guys don't want to back us up with
whatever we want to do we're going to
cut such and such off oh hey germany
right all those things
because those eastern blot man they all
love us right
you know there's there are there are two
allies now you've got oh you know the
brits the french and germans who are
kind of they've been flipping their
middle finger up to us quite a bit for
the last 10 years okay guys that's your
stance cool we're going to continue to
be friends with romania and hungary and
lithuania estonia yeah we're going to
back them up
because they're they're on the line with
russia you guys screw you guys take care
of yourselves for a little while right
just like trump
wanted to pull funding from nato like
you guys are gonna start funding this
right he took a little bit hard line
with our allies like hey we're gonna
treat you guys like adults now we're
gonna cut some of your funding you guys
are gonna start contributing that's not
a horrible approach
right accountability
uh own it right you guys want nato you
like nedo don't you right you guys like
that security of having us backing you
up from across the pond
just like we did in world war ii yeah
y'all know
so check it out here's some new rules
we're gonna play by
you know we've been funding this thing
we're gonna take a step back we're gonna
let you guys take the lead for a little
while see how you do with it right
there's nothing wrong with that no and i
think trump was trying to do that i
don't
you know um
and you know
let's face it
those leaders in in those countries man
they they they led the way they're they
are the binds ahead of biden europe
america likes to think we lead the way
with everything like we led away with
this
crazy goopy leftist presidency and all
this stuff no man europe was way ahead
of us on that stuff their leaders right
have been crazy liberals for freaking
you know five ten years now they they
definitely got to jump on that for us
you know not that that's a good thing
so
until we just take a step back and say
hey guys deal with it
i do think you know clearly in this case
war with russia what would china man
you're talking something that would
affect the entire world and be so
expensive for all parties right putin
here's the reality putin doesn't want
war with us it would destroy his country
have the money for it exactly
so
choke them out
oh that means cutting off that pipeline
we told them they could have
[__] that's going to mean we have to
freaking admit we were wrong
sanctions russia can't afford and
even more so right like
if the rest of the world
distances themselves from russia stops
and then in russia standing there with a
china that's kind of their ally but also
trying to shove them out of the way at
the same time
in iran
that's your friends putin the rest of
the world is kind of tired of y'all's
crap
and
they go back to behaving
right
and ultimately again root cause why does
russia want this
why does russia want it we just
identify that we can cut them off at the
knees
it's just so frustrating man and again
you know always step back and say you
know what
i don't know everything i don't i don't
i don't get to peek behind that curtain
right like clearly biden or whoever's
running our country um
vice president harris
they know way more than i do so i'm
always going to give any administration
a little bit of benefit of a doubt right
like
you know i always i i
hated growing up in the military where
some key leader would be like well you
just don't understand the big picture
and then as i got older i realized that
i don't understand the big thing they
didn't understand it either dude yeah of
course they didn't either right like
that was their way of saying like yeah
we don't really know what the hell is
going on either but now that i'm older i
do have an acceptance that i don't have
the big picture and i never will right
none of us will ever know what the
president of the united states knows
right like there's no security clearance
out there that touches what that guy
gets to know or that gal presumably one
day
um no so you as us as the guys who work
for that commander-in-chief always have
to kind of sit back and go okay they
know more than us
so i always try to keep that in reserve
you know like that to keep me from
creating assumptions and assertions
that is
realizing that my assumptions and my
assertions are always going to be
less informed right right yeah they've
got
massive
intel networks briefing every day
sources all over the world like they got
some they got some information right
still i like to think that they do some
good stuff with it me too i'm like
please god um because right now man what
we've gotten ourselves into is scary and
again
and especially
like you talking about china what if
china makes a move on taiwan now
like they're not sitting over there
going oh well if
america's clear ukraine the withdrawal
from afghanistan
is what set this stage right like i
don't know anybody except for like some
staunch left supporters of
i don't even know if there's any biden
supporters left but there are the the
democrats right who are just never going
to say that they were wrong for voting
for him or that he anything they've done
is wrong right this is how our system
works
but the reality is
any
objective synthetic thinker
knows that this all started with our
withdrawal from afghanistan and the
weakness that was just
you know
sent out across the world worldwide
so what was the
or was there a straw that broke the
camel's back that made you say i'm i'm
gonna go and run
cause i mean let's face it here you are
how old you say you are just turned 46
just turned 46 you got businesses you
got a cool woman in your life
you got a a nice place to live or
whatever yeah
seems like you could be going into
actual literal retirement mode yeah like
instead of enjoying your life mode right
and that's where i was at and i've been
working towards it pretty hard
you know even living in wilmington drove
me insane stop lights and traffic and
you know hey just i flew in yesterday
because
you know melissa and i bought 62 acres
about an hour outside of wilmington
you know it came with three donkeys and
chickens and fenced in pastures and we
turn our dogs loose and
i mean if i want to walk around my yard
naked you know what i mean it's that
type of country you know it's the same
way i grew up
and i think you know whether that's
genetic or not i've always craved it i
like to be in places where it's just
quiet
you know growing up on the coast
you know the water and then
because of a dare
um or someone talking smack i went to
dive school wound up on a dive team i
wanted to be on the mountain team i went
to afghanistan and fell in love with the
mountains because before afghanistan i
had done some training in colorado but
not really enough to
fall in love with the mountains and the
thin air and all that
well we went to afghanistan man and i
was just man you know i remember looking
around like in tora bore and stuff and
and
you know um
like wow this would be some amazing
snowboarding like what are they doing
here you know and at the time i didn't
realize that it actually was a
destination back in the 60s yeah my
stepmother
and her friends all went to kabul in the
late 60s to smoke weed
yeah my stepmother is she was uh it's so
funny my mom being a north carolina girl
country girl farm girl my grandfather
was a farmer um and then my stepmother's
from
out here oh yeah she was from like uh
uh oh i should say oh where was she
forget her hometown but um
um between here in l.a and uh so she was
like a hippie a little bit in the 60s
turned into i mean if she was traveling
to africa smoking popular 60s
but not like uh not like an
anti-government hippie just like a
california young girl you know whatever
and so cool stories you know and i had
no idea there was that part of
afghanistan that it was actually very
western and
modern during the 60s you know kabul you
look at pictures there's you know the
roads are nice it's clean people are
smiling you know
so anyway yeah man i'm just not into the
city you know that i would these days
you put me behind a tractor or a combine
i gotta go six mile an hour for 10 miles
no stress
i'm not even gonna whatever you know i
don't care
because living out there i'm rarely in a
hurry i have days that i have work to do
and clients and guys to shoot with in
classes but on my days off man i'm my
boss you know and don't get me wrong i
can be my own kind of a pain in my ass
but i'm flexible with my time
so no stress you know um
got out of the city everything's awesome
it sucks for melissa because she drives
almost an hour every day one way to her
but you know she's she's chill um
you know she loves to listen to her
podcast and all that kind of stuff and
you know she's a dentist so she works
four days a week
and um so friday she gets to go and do
whatever she wants or whatever so you
know before we did it you know i was
like hey are you sure because our price
is cute man and i found it by accident i
just happened to be driving down that
road took a different route home one day
and uh saw the for sale sign pulled off
the side of the road put up google maps
you could kind of see the property lines
i was like ooh called the realtor man we
closed on it
so yeah you know
there are days where like my most
intelligent conversation is with a
couple of donkeys and some dogs i don't
even see people
you know my nearest neighbor well my
nearest nearest neighbor is like some
methods that live like i don't know half
a mile through the woods um we basically
have an agreement that
um they set up my business and you know
i started their business and their
trailer doesn't burn down right um you
know how meth cook houses sometimes you
know catch on fire so we're good you
know we're good every now and then i'll
wake up and like
you know i can hear their music playing
at like four in the morning or something
but other than that they don't mess with
me i don't mess with them they're just
redneck meth heads
and then the other neighbor man it's
kind of cool she lives like 1.2 miles
away and she's completely deaf
so she can't hear the range
other than that no one lives within two
miles of us you know so we get out there
and shoot and shoot no one cares so it's
real cool man
yeah so
we were planning on moving to idaho
as the costs were going up we're
starting to look at montana as well
because a couple years ago montana being
really expensive
idaho was still like all right and the
cool thing about idaho for me is while
the rockies aren't as high there they're
not they'll have the same elevation and
say colorado or wherever
idaho is like
60 public land
lots of hunting access
and um
i i like hunting but i like being on
those mountains man you know just it's
quiet
most time it's just me and melissa
but um yeah man we we'd found a couple
different places we were looking at one
place very seriously in idaho city just
north idaho city and uh all right and
then
everything in america started happening
because man that's where i was at you
know my business is doing great i mean
melissa's a dentist so like
or she ready to pull chalks too yeah
yeah and for her to do that's kind of a
big deal like um
you know clearly like i said i can i can
pack a backpack and a duffel bag and
move you know grab some guns out of the
safe let's go
um
she clearly you know i mean she
you know she's got 18 or 19 employees
all females
um now it's always fun because they've
always got something going on you know
i don't want to call it drama because
that would be dismissing it but
the dynamics in that office are always
fun to listen to you know because i have
team dynamic stuff and then i get to
listen to melissa about her team
dynamics and it's like
a lot of the same stuff that we would
deal with only with a a hint of
you know the lady stuff you know and i'm
like wow i don't envy her at all because
at least like on a team man in theory
you could always go out back and sort it
out you know
at least go in there and put the gloves
on and sort that [__] out right she
doesn't have that option
so yeah man um
we were really close to pulling the
trigger on moving and we had talked
about it for years like our first date
that we claim is our first date right we
were when she and i met
she and her boyfriend just broke up me
and the girl i was dating had just broke
up and we were real skeptical of each
other we'd known each other from the gym
and
kind of looked at each other like i
don't know who's that punk who's that
punk you know both very strong
personalities she's her own boss same
with me i've been a boss for a while now
i don't really
and that dynamic was just so interesting
as we came together we kind of kept it
quiet that we were seeing each other so
our
kind of our announcement to all of our
friends and you know how a gym can be
everyone's friends from the gym and um
we did a hike across the bob marshall
wilderness out in montana right but it
wasn't supposed to be a hike across it
was supposed to be a loop back to the
car two days
20 some miles
well that night we hit our turnaround
point we woke up in the morning and
there was smoke everywhere largest
forest fire ever in the flathead
national forest
and the bob marshall was inside the
flathead
uh oh now what so now we are running
from a forest fire all the way across
the bob marshall so it was like 70 or so
miles and we didn't even have the food
for it
and right now in the console of my truck
or protein bars they're not mine
they're for her
her favorite protein bars because the
last thing anyone wants is for melissa
to get hungry
angry is she a hangry woman
so melissa is uh melissa is half german
and half japanese
i live with the axis powers
keeping her fed is a priority
i'm telling you man
and it's not like a gradual descent
everything's cool and now she just wants
to tear your throat
and you don't know it yeah and you don't
even know it's coming i'm like i'm
blissfully you know like dude you know
i'm not real crazy or anything about my
diet anymore right like my thing is like
i just you know i started getting older
started not having abs as much so i just
quit eating breakfast and lunch simple
some people call that intermittent
fasting i call it screw it less calories
um no fancy diet names here
and uh no dude she needs to eat so we
have to keep her fed
but yeah uh we run out of food running
across to bob marshall so you're one day
in when the forest fire hits
and how many what's the total day uh we
wound up doing it in uh all in in two
and a half two and three quarters days
and seventy something miles man we had
to go across the continental device like
you gotta climb like nine thousand feet
in like a mile and a half it's like zig
zig zig i remember going up the the um
the zigzags right
the switchbacks and i remember looking
up the trail would go here to here and
on the trail right there were three or
four mule deer and i was looking up at
their bellies like right there but i
could still almost touch them
like this anyway i blessed her hartman
on that trip across the bottom marshall
she learned how to read a topic map
freaking was running the gps she'd never
done that stuff before she didn't i mean
she'd been ice climb mountain climb
hiked in all kinds of national forests
her and her buddy from dental school
were like adventurous young ladies out
in some cases they tell me stories i'm
like that was dumb and dangerous you
could have been one of those missing
person stories and they're like yeah
probably
well anyway just that type of person man
and um
we had to cross the white river and it's
in august so it's snowmelt you know
and man i made a huge mistake freaking
so because she's so physically fit but
dude she's she's 120
maybe 125 pounds at this time
and i'm like oh this is a good place to
cross this river i mean it's rolling
it's like knee-deep to me
that's halfway her quads
i gotta cross drop my pack and i could
see she was struggling right and
i'm pretty sure footed i've been in the
woods backpacks walking stick she's got
a walking stick but it's scattered we're
starting to leverage her off
and man i got back out there and you
know the rocks under that water slick
and i'm like get out there man and i put
my hand on her backpack and she slipped
we went in the drink
all right i was lucky i got underneath
her and man it was like that whole push
her up get me some air
go back under and then i got scuffed up
my whole backside my knees this whole
side just beat up she's got her pack on
so she's pretty protected or whatever
and luckily there's a curve in the river
because a couple hundred meters on down
this way is the salmon river if we'd
gone in that go through those little bit
of falls and into that river we would
have died right
luckily little curve man it washed us up
on the shore and we kind of crawled out
laid there
warm in the afternoon but man the water
was cold real cold and like cold enough
to where i'm bleeding and scuffed up but
i can't feel it and i'm like oh i'm
gonna be sore
this is gonna suck
she rolls over and looks at me she's
like oh you saved my life and i was like
yeah we're going to go with that story
because i picked that river crossing man
i almost killed her
almost killed that girl man
and i will never
yeah
it it
spooks me even talking about it right
freaking
and because who would have believed
afterwards
that
i chose that river crossing right they'd
be like oh he did that on purpose he
drowned that girl
but no we were new and i was like oh i'm
in love with this chick and stuff and i
it horrified me that i had made such
a stupid decision
just
stupid
but we were running from a forest fire
whatever freaking haste all that
i did learn that she's not one of us you
know i still have to be careful
she's smaller so on and so forth
anyway man
we get across there whatever freaking
that was like our first date coming out
of the closet as far as us dating and
stuff and man it was ever since then
every vacation we took was to the
mountains
she
she wants to climb everest
which clearly puts me in an interesting
position because i don't give a damn
about climbing everest
but i can't just let my girlfriend now
right i'm like i guess i'm gonna have to
go up there too or i just suck it up and
say hey honey i'm gonna wait for you in
a base camp freaking hang out with these
potheads and freaking i'll talk to you
on the radio are you dead no you're good
keep going right summit that thing but
now so we start climbing the 14ers in
colorado so
we're doing that stuff man just falling
in love with the mountains point being
is we want to move to the mountains her
best friend from dental schools in
colorado or
originally talking about going to
colorado and then it
got a little california on us um lots of
public hunting land there
one of two states left that you can get
over the counter tags for elk
no big deal um and if you leave denver
boulder right go up anywhere freaking
it's still dodge trucks with bumpers you
know it's still diesel pickups and good
old ranch boys you know so i would do
collar if you want it but we kind of
figured on on i know a bunch of my
friends moved to idaho and probably a
bunch of your friends have moved to
idaho it's like the
where everybody's going it's the last
conservative holdout i guess
well
we were that close man we were getting
ready to pull the trigger on moving and
like i said a big deal for her with her
practice
and then everything started happening
the pandemic the weirdness it's it got
to the point where like i was like wow
one year ago if you'd asked me how long
it was going to take for us to get right
here i would have said 20 years but
somehow the u.s got put on fast forward
to its you know progressive decline
and every nation has it
right history tells us every culture
fails
and we have some very distinct parallels
to the last greatest culture right the
last greatest
um city-state rome
right the roman empire
you know huge debt
a nation and culture founded on slavery
on the backs of slaves right there are
many parallels
a nation who cared more about
entertaining themselves than protecting
their borders right it's some spooky
parallels
and i'm like
and then i'm talking to my very good
friend ellario pontano
ellario if you google him he was the
marine in fallujah
that shot and killed two
terrorist dirtbags
and then was charged with their murders
lieutenant type um so you know
he um
his platoon he had lost some boys today
before so he was an enlisted guy scout
sniper
was working on wall street
911 happened doing great for himself and
his family smart guy
um real smart dude and
911 happened and he got back in
and then in fallujah man you know for
killing two very clearly terrorists
right remember fallujah get out
or fight us anybody that stays you're a
bad guy and they were bad guys they had
weapons in the trunk so on and so forth
what got weird for uh you can look his
story up but bottom line they charged
him with murder
two counts of it and for how many months
of his life he was
having to defend himself against the
nation that he's
so much loved and went to war for
well illario ran for congress in 2010
and 2012.
i bet right before then 2008 timeframe
when i opened my gym
so i watched and and as he was running i
was still very apolitical
wasn't really interested so on and so
forth
the primaries didn't work out for him
they were fighting him and another
fellow who is now the incumbent a guy
named david rouser they were fighting
for that area
and what they were really fighting was a
30-some year democrat incumbent
well between the two of them they did
finally oust him and but david rouser
bested illario in the primaries he just
had more pool in one highly populated
segment
of that district and you know
david came out the winner
um since then you know l'oreal he became
the director of veterans affairs and
stuff for north carolina long story
short man just you know has dedicated
his life to trying to take care of
service members and uh just just a great
guy but
last easter day we're sitting on the
tailgate in my truck out of the range
and we're just chatting he
took a job at syracuse university and
was living up in syracuse down visiting
and we were just chatting about things
the nation the state of it and so on and
so forth and i was like hey man
so
[Applause]
i was thinking about
potentially
maybe
dude he hops off the tailgate and he's
like he can get excited you know like
when he gets inside he's really excited
he's like yes if there's ever a time
it's 20 22 the nation's ready for it the
climate needs you it's this this he just
got he didn't even let me finish he knew
what i was going to say and which i
thought was pretty cool because i don't
necessarily think i you know
broadcast something like that especially
something so out of that field for me
but he just had a feeling
and it was funny because it's easter day
and he's like you know what i was like
well i'm just kicking around i'm not
sure he's like it's easter day and
there's
it's clearly god sent me here today to
tell you that you must absolutely do
this and i'm sitting there going
not really where i thought this was
gonna go but now i'm like all right all
right so
if he feels this strongly about it he's
the first person that i've even
mentioned it to
maybe this is something i should look at
and at the time i'm still like i just
want to move to idaho i just want to go
hunting that's going to be left alone
mind my own business
then i realized that the reason we're
where we're at
is because dudes like me have been
minding our own damn business while the
left has rallied protested organized
and executed a subversion campaign that
the world
like the world's never seen before
right a very successful subversion
campaign
and uh so fast forward a little bit so
that was easter day
lauria puts me in contact with the folks
who are now my consultant team and all
that we start kind of exploring all
right let's come up with some courses of
action see if they're viable let's see
if this works well north carolina and
the census picks up an extra
an additional an extra an additional
seat so we had 13 now we're gonna have
uh representatives u.s house of
representatives
yeah man um
so we're like okay let's just we're
gonna have to wait and see because right
now i live in that same district with
the incumbent david rouser and
by all means a pretty squared away dude
um he hasn't
he hasn't done anything to really upset
anybody he's not a rhino i wouldn't say
he's like
you know the champion of all things
patriotic america either but what he has
then is take care of his district which
is agriculture yeah
i think he's
probably going to become
the
lead on the agriculture committee
at least that's what i've heard um
well so we decided hey look if i'm going
to run i'm going to have to wait to see
the new districts because challenging
rouser is probably a losing thing i'm
not doing america any good challenging
an opponent that can't be be that's not
a good strategy right
and you know especially a guy that's
doing what he's supposed to do
representing his district that's right i
am all for challenging republican
incumbents that suck
they need to go right and i've said
numerous times re-elect no one
re-elect no one but the reality is there
are still some good dudes up there who
need some backup they need a qrf right
so
the new districts come out and
the county i live in
and
a couple others to include cumberland
county fayetteville fort bragg harnett
county this little block this almost a
square right in the middle of north
carolina mostly rural
and i live in it and it's got fed all
fort bragg i'm like oh
okay
now we're making sense and no incumbent
damn right like it's ready made it's
just sitting there ready for me to go
whoo i'm gonna run for congress
so we announced man and um
we'd already put it together we're ready
right we're just waiting on those
districts and it was like okay this this
makes sense
right i can do this and and hopefully go
do some be part of positive change help
correct this
trajectory i joke that it's like a 308
trajectory and we're trying to make it
like a like a you know a 375 enabler
trajectory you know let's let's let's
let's flatten this curve a little bit
not the pandemic curve let's like
flatten this trajectory curve that
america has been placed on by
crazy socialists um
so yeah man it happened we said okay
cool this makes sense but you asked like
the straw that broke the camel's back
man
i'm not usually a super sentimental type
person or whatever but that
my father passed last summer we held his
memorial service over july the fourth
weekend
my niece my older sister's daughter
like i said motor sister is a very
successful
uh pediatric pediatric endocrinologist
my niece has never known what it's like
to miss a meal
um
she doesn't know suffering
and in a lot of ways i'm kind of that
guy's like this next generation sucks
and these boys need to learn how to
change the oil in their car
all right i mean we all get into that
sometimes we're like man this next gen
is just weak
but i'm looking at my knees so is this
beautiful young lady lacrosse player
she's almost six foot tall
stud
freaking a gear ahead in school super
intelligent right um
not only is my sister you know more
aggressive than me she's
a brilliant mind
so her son and her daughter got some of
this
well anyway
they come to the house my niece is
playing you know she's my sister's in
biotech so she lives in boston
so my niece is a city kid so she's out
on my you know property riding the
four-wheeler playing with the dogs
freaking throwing you know the dummies
into the pond for the the retriever
and i'm just looking at her
and like she's never known what it's
like to not have wi-fi
that level of luxury right like that's
america i mean even the poorest people
in america today have it pretty good
like
homeless people in america you know
have it pretty good you know we take
care of even our poorest
but i'm looking at her i'm just like huh
she's never known what it's like like
since she's been able to use a
smartphone they've had wi-fi on
airplanes
i was like i don't want to i don't want
her to ever know what it's like not to
live in that type of luxury i don't want
her to live in what western mosul looked
like in 2005 2006 and then for the whole
entire nineveh to be burned to the
ground and crushed and the indigenous
folks of nineveh city to be murdered by
isis right like i don't want her to know
an america at war with itself and if we
keep on this trajectory that is a
potential
course
and that scares the [__] out of me and i
don't know that any of us will be alive
to see that type of demise of our
culture but she might be
right she's 16 years old
and that was a day that i was like
all right
let's do it
july the fourth weekend last year
and it wasn't because it was july the
fourth weekend it just happened right
this is kind of a i guess a cool story
and i'm not a very sentimental type
person or whatever but it was about my
knees it was the weekend that we
memorialized my father's life
and i was like okay
eight years is all i'll do that that
will put me at 55 years old
and then i'll retire
and i was hopefully if i can continue
the path that i'm on i would maintain
physical fitness and at 55
i'll still be fit enough to go hunt
whatever crazy animal i want to chase
around the mountain
but i was like you know what it
if not me then who
i'm at a place where i can like i said
me and melissa don't have children
and you know as well as i do right like
overseas
i i had different times in my life where
i wouldn't take a married guy with kids
on my team i would take that young
ranger
because i know he wasn't distracted i
built a team there for a while that was
just
there were some scary young men they had
no distractions i have sent men home for
being on the phone too often too late
arguing with their spouses hey go go
home sort it out
i'll see you in a few weeks
or bro
hey man i understand if you don't want
to come back go take care of your family
but you don't get to be here running
operations with us while you got that
distraction on your on your mind
so i don't have kids man i can go
and go to dc
and be fully invested right while
another person like me who might be
considering a run that has has two kids
they need to go to a ballet concert or a
ballet recital a concert
or a band concert or a soccer game or a
lacrosse game or a football game or
whatever you'll be sitting at your desk
i can get to work yeah
you'll be making [__] happen
oh the whole desk image just ruined it
probably can we not put me behind a desk
um
yeah you know
i was joking i was like um
i want to make c-span the most watched
news network oh i like that
i want people yeah i want people to like
be tuning in to see it like okay what in
the world has tony and
so
this is kind of cool right
aoc in that weird bunch they call them
the squad right clearly not an infantry
squad
so myself jay collins is a seventh
grouper uh who's running in florida he's
an amputee
he's a stud man stud of studs and uh so
he's running down in florida he's doing
really well as well we were joking that
hey man if they can have the squad we'll
be the jtf
the joint task force right
and that's the thing man we're trying
really hard to get off america yeah jtf
america that's a caucus right the jtf
caucus the veterans college whatever you
want to cause right
but yeah man that that is how i made
that decision as like you know hey man
there is an entire generation of america
that
that that needs to be taken care of that
needs to be set up for success
and i feel like it's my generation the
the
you know the the
40 the 60 year olds right now who have
failed this last generation and allowed
all this to happen because we were just
hard-working conservatives that minded
our own damn business and by minding our
own damn business we elected these
spineless cowards that went to dc and
sold us out time after time again
compromised our rights away right
everybody's heard to say and
conservatives haven't conserved a damn
thing because conservatives are good
people and they think dealing with the
left
is a is is a rational thing the problem
is the left are not rational people they
only want what they want and they're not
going to compromise the right just keeps
compromising bit by bit by bit every
single right that we hold dear they let
it go
piece by piece by peace and that's how
this nation can fall right there's
clearly no nation on this planet it's
going to invade us
right and get anywhere you know the old
there's a gun behind every blade of
grass right the japanese knew they
weren't hitting this mainland right
china knows they can't
same with russia
the only way we can fall is if we allow
it and we have allowed this country to
get where it's at and when i say we i
mean
us all of us good people it's our fault
i mean i made him post on social a
couple weeks ago a week ago whenever it
was and i i tired of
um you know the biggest problem in
america question one
it's us
right it's us not being involved
i ask people
who who's your representative
what district do you live in who's your
county commissioners are you involved in
the local gop are you
we're not man
we're not
and all the while the democrats are
organized
super organized
we're not
and that's how we lose we don't even
vote the average voter in a primary on
the republican conservative side
it's 57 years and older
young conservatives are not involved and
and part of that problem is is a lot of
young people in this next generation
they
they don't realize that posting comments
and and things on social media it's not
real action
right and i'm not even being funny about
it it used to be it used to be kind of a
joke that you know like okay you think
fighting on the internet it's not like a
real fight
no man it's like they really they have
begun equating
saying things on the internet as if it's
a real thing that somehow influences
right because we use the term
influencers
you're not influencing a damn thing you
know even with the little bit of
followers i have on instagram i ask
people i beg i say i am pleading with
you please go join your local gop how do
we get involved tony go join your local
gmp
and well how do i do that
okay
once you get on your phone
and i want you to pull up google or
whatever search engine you're using
these days
i want you to type in your county's name
and the letters gop
or republican party
and you will find their website and you
will find out that they have monthly
meetings and you'll go there and you'll
find out that on average there's only 30
people there
no one
and they are the conservative like bras
they want to be involved
but they're the ones that will tell you
like in north carolina
they want 15
000 volunteers
to watch the polls
to sit at the polls 15 000 people
it's not enough that's a very very low
number they probably need double that
because early voting
two and a half weeks long oh right you
gotta have people watch the polls for
four hour shifts two shifts per day you
need two people per shift
at least right
the the need is there and
you know always i was joking this
generation if they want something just
like our generation too if we want
something and we want to participate in
something
and it becomes our hobby man we know
everything about it
because we youtube it and we google it
and we and we
it's all right here everything you want
to know everything known to mankind
except for classified information and
some of that is all right here it's in
the phone right
so if you want to know how to get
involved man it's right here
and when you go and you talk to those
people at those meetings yeah man
they're the fanatics they're the really
passionate conservative republicans who
really do want to change that republican
party in the image of the old gop the
rhinos and all that
if you go to these gop meetings man
they're mad at the republican party
they're the republican party and they're
mad at the republican party
they want to get rid of the rhinos
they're they're the people who want to
renovate that party because you know i
hear people say
um
you know
maybe we need a third party
okay that's not a viable course of
action america's not ready for it it
would take the democrats and the
republicans getting together and
deciding that the third party was a good
thing
deciding to surrender whatever power
that does they're not gonna do power is
like uh matter it never goes away it can
be transferred
right and we have transferred willingly
power throughout our nation's history
right
a good example is when we gave
minorities the right to vote
right
so we are capable of doing we gave women
the right to vote
right so we have transferred power
willingly typically speaking throughout
not american human history
power's transferred because it's taken
it's rarely given
but that's what makes america special is
that we have given power
willingly
in an effort to create this amazing
country you
know but yeah man freaking uh
you know
it
it's going to take us getting involved
the biggest problem on this planet is
today is it
or in america today that's going to
continue to lead us down this path and
not change the trajectory is us minding
our own business
and i get it man you got a job you got a
couple kids and
if you don't get involved right because
what happens
when you go to the gop when your
8 10 and 14 year old
see you getting involved what are they
going to grow up to do
it's setting the example right set the
example to exceed the standards all that
military leadership talk
it's not [__] you know i know you
know it's not [__] you wrote an
entire book about it a couple of them
right
you know
setting the example for your children is
not just making sure they're taken care
of
right
we we have got to get involved and if we
don't man
well like i said our adversary they're
very involved they're organized and
they're scary
i ask people i'm like name one thing the
left has wanted in the last six years
they haven't gotten
one is complete
reversal of the second amendment
why
because there's a bunch of people out
there with guns that ain't gonna let it
happen other than that
every
niche special interest they've ever
wanted they've gotten it and now it's
like they're just bored looking for [__]
you know what i mean like the
transgender is freaking in college
sports like all right we're just going
to make up some stuff that actually goes
against our whole feminist movement like
it's like they're bored like we got
everything we want
what else can we take from them
but they're going to continue to take
because
whether or not most lefts
truly want communism there are enough
folks out there that do that believe
that communism is the right path
well the rest of them will follow
because they actually have leaders
right you mean you tell me hillary
clinton is not an effective leader i'm
not saying she's a good leader i'm
saying she's an effective leader right
like putin is an effective leader he's
not a good person
she's definitely not a good person
she's effective and one thing hillary
clinton hadn't gotten that she wanted
presidency and i don't know that she's
done yet
scary [__] man
well we fighted that one out soon
uh i'm
hopefully
i got a i got a factory down in asheboro
north carolina i think it's the sixth
district hopefully at some point when i
cut down there in the next several
months we can link up definitely and
hang out you gotta come check out the
factory for sure i haven't been there
yet but um actually we have two
factories we're consolidating in the
process of consolidating right now but
uh hundreds of jobs for hard-working
people funny thing man that district
i think because we've had so many
changes
that is probably the district that
christian castanelli is going to run in
he's one of those eight gbs
lieutenant colonel type seventh grouper
uh you know chatted quite a bit and um
it's gonna be a real tough race for him
as well he had more counting
and now they redistrict again and and
like i said it could redistrict another
time it's going to the courts this week
it's frustrating uh and it's you know do
you know right now which
where you're running
for right now okay but it could change
so yeah it was that new fourth which was
samson county
uh johnson county a little bit of wayne
county harnett county and cumberland
county and now it's the new new
13th and that's duplin county sampson
county johnson county a little bit of
wayne county and southern wake county
and it's so weird
because these new districts they don't
hold communities together it was like
again it was a the republicans were
trying to make the dems happy
get some stuff pushed through that would
actually work
meet all the numbers because the
districts have to have equal numbers
right
and to do that
it
you know you've got to get a city in
here and a part of a city over there and
it's not like it's like okay just pick
this region you know it's more complex
than that
so this new district again
man and like i said this goes back to
republicans trying to make the democrats
happy the democrats suckered him again
they
so we have an activist very left-leaning
supreme court in north carolina
and
so when these new districts they ch the
democrats challenged them it went to the
supreme court they booted them they had
to rewrite them so they rebuilt them the
house did a set and i like that map
pretty good this new one i don't dislike
it it's just not my favorite because i
lost cumberland county i want to
represent
fayetteville for brag yeah it's it's
kind of personal
so
the um
this week they have to go to a three
panel
court three judge panel in the court and
that's two conservatives one liberal it
will get the thumbs up there
most likely the democrats will
challenge it again but the the shasti
like sinister part is when they were
building these maps it was bipartisan
in the senate and in the house both
parties working together they created
these maps dems gave them a thumb up it
went in a vote dems all voted against it
suckers
now what because it's divided half and
half
and one republican
voted with the democrats
that sets the precedents for it to go to
the court and then toss it out they can
be like look y'all don't even agree on
it it's clearly bipartisan this is
supposed to be or is clearly partisan
they set them up again it's like you
guys are bending over backwards when are
you just going to draw the line in the
sand they could draw the line in the
sand and take it to the you know u.s
house or u.s supreme court
that's expensive and it takes a fight
and time lots of time and they're
worried about the time because
we've already pushed our primaries back
from march to may they're probably going
to get pushed back to june now that's
getting closer and closer to the general
election in november
they could in theory move that right
that you know that november election
date is not a hard set date the state
can choose a different day they could
push it to january but that cuts off
the whole next cycle that pushes into
the next cycle
what do you do now
and we're in such uncharted territory
and i just don't have faith that the
republicans
right now know how to deal with this
fight
um
and the democrats almost like i said
it's almost like they're just trying to
see what they can get away with
but they're panicking the democrats know
right what's coming in this med terms so
these new our new districts
they are so close to any other year
they would most of them be 50 50 splits
they could go either way they'd all be
swinging districts but because of this
anticipated red wave
there they set them up it looks more
like they set them up on purpose to be
republican
very much favor the republicans and of
course did they well certainly but the
north carolina constitution says it is
the role duty responsibility of the
general assembly to set the districts
so of course it's going to be partisan
right because rarely if ever is your
house and senate 50 50.
right it just doesn't happen
so there's a whole constitutional battle
here and um state constitution and i
think people really understand how
important your state constitution is
right like when our government was set
up it was supposed to be you know all
these
states these
nations
of the united states
and we've gotten away from that the
federal government's gotten too big and
that's one of my big things man like hey
let's return
that federal government let's put it
back in its constitutionally
limited box and put the lid back on it
because that monster has climbed out of
that box and gone all over the place
and i would say like heck man if you
could simply attempt let's say we got a
70 solution on getting our federal
government back to its constitutional
limitations we would solve
over half of america's problems
with the federal government just return
it to what that constitution says
i don't know man they i just feel like
too often folks up in dc they use the
constitution as toilet paper
instead of reading it for exactly what
it stated
it's it's heartbreaking man
[Applause]
well like you said it's going to be a
battle um
it is a battle
i know you mentioned about how to what
to do for people to get to help out
you know locally where they're at how
can people
i think this is probably a pretty good
place to wrap up because we've been
going for over four hours but
if people want to support you um
we got tony cowden.com right that's the
main that is the campaign website the
campaign website um you're on instagram
you just said mm-hmm tony underscore
cowden underscore four the letter four
or excuse me the number four is there a
letter for no
number four
nc and then i have two facebook pages my
personal tony cotton and then um the
campaign tony accountant they're both me
all right and then
you've got a youtube channel which i saw
yeah i don't do much with it i was gonna
say you have one video yeah but you know
i don't wanna uh i think i've got like
freaking three tony tony gets after so i
don't know maybe tonight you're gonna
post from 87 videos i don't know yeah i
uh youtube's just never been my favorite
for whatever reason um and i've had
numerous youtube channels right i've got
the one right now like you said it's got
like a couple videos maybe on it and
then like but you know youtube was a big
thing when i had the gym i had lots of
videos on it and just something happened
where with the whole shooting gun thing
instagram became my main platform
and
as much as i i don't really like social
i don't like the whole idea of it i mean
i'd much rather go back to just you know
but the it seemed that at least the
evolution of it all i don't know if it
was even by design that yeah the
instagram page was what grew and
funneled me
business whereas when i had the gym
facebook i mean it's called facebook so
local so now i'm having to get back
after facebook because the campaign is
very local got it but yeah man the
reality is and this sucks man because
i've spent my entire life being pretty
independent i i've never had to ask
anybody for money and it's weird
the reality of this whole mess and it is
a mess because there needs to be
campaign finance reform
the reality is
if the campaign's not funded i don't get
to advertise and there's no face or
there's no recognition there's a name
face recognition and i won't get the
votes
and you know strategically speaking you
know we're addressing you know
fundraising
talking to donors and then there are
voters and they're not always the same
people
we've done really well so far the soft
bro net just like you having me on here
been on a bunch of different other guys
and
when i launched that soft network man
just started sharing it
and we raised 132 grand in like 13 days
over christmas
and that's what got people going well
wait who's this dude
where's this guy coming from
and you know there's always this the
there's some contention that
oh you're not getting your funds from
the district well i don't even know
where the district is you know how hard
it is to get someone to donate to your
campaign when they don't even know if
you live in their district or not yeah
you think the democrats don't know that
of course they do right what they're
doing is creating voter apathy where
it's like whatever
so they won't donate
and they're not going to go vote
it's a strategy it's not new i've done
it before
so yeah man this is where you know
that's that's the asking for money thing
is hard
but
here's the cool part
that 132 000
the number one num the number one
donated amount was 50
we had
1600 or 1500 individual donors from
across the nation all 50 states
over christmas
when people don't have extra income
because they're spending on their
christmas presents
donating this campaign that's a clear
signal
or it should be a clear signal to the
folks up in dc and everywhere else
that the american public is tired of
their [__]
excuse my language but that's what it is
and they they want
normal people i don't know if i fall in
that category that well or not they want
real people who have never sought out
politics
you know uh before we got on i was
joking and telling you about the um my
opponent who's a state house rep
and
they they call him the al gore of
north carolina politics because he sold
out those kind of taxpayers and sent tax
dollars all around the
nation to invest in green energy and so
on and so forth
long story short he didn't like it
i think i might have been with andy
stump when i referred to him as the al
gore of north carolina politics well the
reality is that's what they call him
right like he's a north carolina
member of north carolina house and all
of his contemporaries they all call him
that right he didn't like him well the
other day he
charged up to me and it was
you know he's like
you know and ultimately i was like hey
look man you know
he you can say whatever you want but you
sent that money out and
he told me
he told me i was an
ignorant wannabe
and i was like like i said
i might be ignorant
to how and why y'all do things as
dirty-ass politicians
i was like but i'm not a wannabe like
you created me
men like you are the reason why men like
me are coming for your jobs
we hired you you suck
so now we're gonna fire you and that's
what america wants right now all right
it's clear
america wants and like i said man
we get that jtf up there
dude so yeah
10 bucks
right all right 100 bucks i mean if you
got 2 900 that is the max contribution i
can stand some of those
because that that new district's more
expensive but southern wake county
raleigh that advertising is
it's way more expensive
sure that market right a tv ad in
raleigh is expensive but that's what i
need i need funding people ask what can
i do
10 bucks
right
don't get your starbucks coffee today
give me five bucks
and it's weird man asking for people for
money and then i came to the conclusion
i'm not asking people to give me money
this is an investment in america's
future
because i promise people i will not
become a politician
i would rather die
and sell this nation as people out and
i've put myself in that position before
that i would have died and almost did a
couple of times i feel like i have that
proven track record and people are like
but there's this guy and there's this
guy he's
this veteran and that veteran they went
up there and they sold us out i'm like
i'm not those guys
i'm not those guys what do you want
here i am stepping up help me get there
and if i turn out to be some spineless
dirtbag politician
fire me
right get involved
and fire me but i promise i'm not
capable of being a dirtbag politician
it's not in my genetics
you know it's not even close to
something i could ever be
you know corporations don't have things
that i want i'm not a gear guy right
corporations don't have things i don't
want a boat
i don't want a boat i don't want
i don't desire money i desire
experiences that's why i like hunting
and
you know
with my girlfriend you can't sell me
that i'm not i'm not for sale
so
yeah man if you got a few bucks tony.com
oh i will tell you this man one of the
cool things is when you go to the
website when it pops up there is a
pop-up um that has a video and stuff you
can watch it it's cool videos me telling
you how cool i am or some [__] um
just move past that right underneath it
says dirt bike prize
i'm not a something for nothing type of
guy so last year i got this hair up my
eyes that i was going to get back in the
race of motocross
so i went and bought a brand new kx4 f50
rocking ship
i got an excavator and a
uh
and 63 acres
and i built a motocross track in my
backyard
i'll let my girlfriend going what is
wrong with you
and uh that dirt bike
it's been i got it last november so it's
been whatever a year in a few months it
still has a second take of gas in it i
haven't had time to ride it
so is it going up for auction i donated
it to the campaign nice so it's a raffle
not a routine
it's you know a ten thousand dollar dirt
bike it's never been laid over um i was
cautious getting back into riding so i
took it easy
um
boots helmet nice stuff man i didn't
[__] i bought some nice stuff four
or five sets of riding gear oakley
goggles all that stuff you can buy
chances at it i'm not a something for
nothing type of guy i got an ar coming
on board um and a precision rifle a
custom precision rifle that my buddy who
makes my precision guns freaking
building for us so point being is right
i'm not a something for nothing type of
guy so if you donate a campaign at least
you're getting a chance to win some cool
stuff
so hell yeah
all right
so uh
echo you got anything no we covered it
awesome man um hell yeah thanks for
coming on bro no thank you for having me
thanks for sharing your experiences
thanks for what you've done for america
in the past
and thanks for what you are about to do
for america awesome to meet you man
thank you so much thank you so much for
having me this is this is how we win
absolutely hell yeah thanks brother
thank you
and with that
tony cowden has left the building
heading back to
north kakalaki and i failed to mention i
failed to mention north kakalaki i
failed to mention look i mentioned the
fact that we at origin usa have a
factory in asheboro north carolina which
is awesome but i failed to mention
and it just like these conversations you
don't know where they're going i failed
to mention the fact that when i went
through buds
and
s
t t seal tactical training and then got
to seal team one and then i did three
deployments and then i was in training
cell
with a with my running mate at the time
who i also he was my roommate that whole
time
and he was from north kakalaki
and he's a freaking best guy
awesome guy and a total
stud
um across the board but he's a super
good athlete like a ridiculously good
athlete
like we had
he played
this is the guy who played basketball in
north carolina as a kid
and then he got drafted he was 5 11. he
lost he he
missed a foul shot
and lost like the state championship he
did that you know
so he had he had that but you know he
was still he was in the state
championship and he's obviously a key
player right
uh and
he got he got some he got drafted or
whatever recruited to some d2d3
schools because he was such a good
basketball player
and he ended up he's like listen i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna be a pro obviously
so i'm gonna focus on my education so he
ended up going to university of north
carolina
and while he was there he grew five
inches so he graduated at 6'4
this is a guy you know you go out and
shoot basketball with him and he would
just sit there and hit three pointers
all day yeah so then then
we had alton lee grizzard who was the
navy quarterback and who's himself a
stud that's the guy who is a great
friend of mine and he ended up getting
murdered in in coronado which is awful
but just a stud just a stud across the
board i mean he played he broke all
kinds of records at the naval academy
just a beast
and those two guys got in a little
throwing contest of who could throw a
football further and
my buddy from north kakalaki also played
football
so i'm sitting there watching because i
i'm not even going to participate in
this competition against these two
freaking studs
and
so they started throwing it back and
forth just backing up each time right
right and uh yeah the kid from north
carolina he threw a further one
it was like 65 yards
i'm not gonna wing yeah
and just a beast man
but so whenever i hear north carolina i
always think north kagalaki because
that's how he and you know he had this
funny look he'd give people
me
everybody but when you said north
carolina or if you said north kakalaki
he'd give you a look like of the most
affirming of looks you know like like
that's everything you know like
you know as if you just said
uh you know
chocolate peanut butter milk like oh
that's so good you know it is one of
those things
so i dig it uh very cool to
talk to tony
and you know it's a scrap man yeah it's
a scrap
he's got to go he's going hard in the
paint you know don't harden the paint
um
uh he said something that was that was
interesting and maybe i don't know i
don't follow
public politics as much as maybe others
do
but he did mention something that i
thought that's that that's that's good
this is a good thing to be talking about
and to be thinking about is the the lack
of effectiveness of a linear solution
yeah because man that linear solution
like and that just in everyday club brah
i don't know how to run a country
everyone knows that you know that about
me i don't know
but
i do think that it's going to be
difficult to make decisions for
what 300 million people or whatever you
know what's in the best interest for 300
it's that's hard i understand but if you
kind of simple it down or whatever let's
say i don't know for example your kids
right
if you start implementing linear
solutions with your kids so the kids no
no crying they want a soda
soda pop give them the soda that's the
length of solutions right yeah they're
crying they're unhappy obviously because
they're crying whatever
what's the linear solution exactly right
give them the soda but that causes all
kinds of other problems a lot of them
too by the way not just one other
problem it's like a bunch of other
problems
so i would imagine it'd be that same
formula except times a million
with
running the country in whatever way
so it's like yeah to focus on that
concept where it's like okay sure this
will be a linear solution or
understanding okay that's a solution
that's a linear solution
understand what what would happen then
and he kept saying and then what right
just to be paying attention to that
stuff i think that's a good thing it's a
good move
and i'm not saying no one else pays
attention to that but that's not like
any kind of front-running concept that
people are kind of pushing you know it
doesn't seem like it is yeah hang on i
don't know but i liked it
well if you can lend some support to
tony just look you might not agree with
him on every every topic that there is
uh
maybe see some things a little bit
differently than you
but
the guy's character
and just the fact that he's gonna go up
there and live in his room and make
things happen
help him out if you can
if you want to help out yourself a
little bit too speaking of origin usa we
have a factory in north carolina
kind of two factories right now which
we're consolidating we have factories up
in maine we're building stuff in america
look here's something else you can do to
support america you want to help america
buy american
buy american you need a pair of boots
buy american pair of boots you need a
pair of jeans
buy an american pair of jeans bro have
you ever heard of jake tran
okay so maybe maybe he what he does is
he he kind of breaks down things that
have to do with like
money and power and he makes these cool
youtube videos okay
jake tran so
um one of them one of his recent one
ones were fashion like the evil fashion
industry
and that's what he was talking to me
talk about like how basically fashion is
built by slavery
in other countries oh for sure so have
you not been listening to me for the
past freaking years i i i have and
and mainly just you know you had to hear
it from jake tran bro jake
he did a really really good job well
maybe if i had someone that i worked
with that could put together videos that
kind of extended the things that i was
saying maybe that would have worked out
better i don't know you yeah you know
what you make a good point you make good
points it's my fault for not finding
someone that was more effective in me in
social media and media and media arts
like film again great point but
the way he does it is he does it in
terms of like like you're the evil one
and he's talking to he goes all you have
to do is this just get some slaves and
do it like he'll talk to that's how
he'll make it
does he do that all the time that's his
thing yeah kind of it's kind of
sarcastic but kind of like
like when he'll kind of coming at you a
little bit yeah
he's coming at your sinister side almost
like in certain ones it's more heavy
than others but then he'll be like
what's the heaviest one uh
this one was so heavy it made me
considered actually doing it but
at the end of the day when you stop the
youtube video you're like well i'm not
going to do that you know anyway uh one
about charities like how charities can
defraud the government or something like
that and be like oh he'll say you can do
this this and this with no strings
attached of course and then he'll keep
talking and you're like
see what he did there right so you're
going to start a a charity to
defraud the government is that what you
were saying you almost did that's not
what it's about but i'm saying when you
watch the video you're like that's
actually not a bad idea you know it's
like that kind of thoughts but it's the
way he says it though i'm glad you're
one youtube video away from being
sinister and ripping people off there's
more to it than that yeah
anyway
watch that one about the freaking
fashion industry you're gonna be like
bro yeah that's and i i get what you're
saying when you're like that's what
you've been saying that's what i've been
saying i haven't been saying it
effectively enough for you to understand
apparently no no i understand it but he
like uh he did a better job
okay i'm gonna watch him we'll we'll get
the message right i'll get the message
right so people that will understand
that when you buy some fashion
crap that's made overseas
it was made by slaves
that's what's happening you remember
that one building in i forget where it
was but where it collapsed on all the
all the workers so he starts off like
with that and like just all these yeah
it's crazy and then a lot of it it's all
essentially like borderline free stuff
like as far as how it was made yeah so
so much of it just goes to the trash so
much of it so they're just just yeah who
cares kids whatever that's why you see
sometimes those those high fashion
companies will take their surplus and
just burn it because they want to keep
the the supply low so it demands high
but they misread the next fall season or
whatever yeah yeah and so they gotta
burn it
so let's not support that let's support
freedom let's support america
let's support origin usa
originusa.com
uh also get yourself some jocko fuel i
mean
let's face it you're going to have some
you know whatever
injuries
soreness soreness for sure uh what's the
difference between muscle soreness and
like when you have a joint soreness
well what do you call it when you're if
you did let's say you did weighted dips
yesterday sure hypothetically see
weighted dips every time i do weighted
dips i have i feel like a little bit of
not just soreness in my triceps and
chest but i have a little bit of what is
that called in my shoulders themselves
yeah like joint pain yeah a little bit
but it's minor right right joint
aggravation yeah it's like i think a lot
of the times it'll come obviously from
like certain nutritional elements and
it could be past injuries as well but a
lot of times it's imbalances in certain
places you know so you kind of over
stretch or under stretch certain things
and whatever but well when you have
joint aggravation sure you can take like
joint warfare if you have muscle
soreness you can take milk yep and these
are nutritional elements that can
improve that are going to improve these
scenarios unfortunate scenarios and kind
of fortunate because at least you were
able to do them exactly you were able to
get after it and it's part of the game
so i learned early on and i was okay so
i make my daughter do little workouts
yeah sometimes it's punishment sometimes
says hey this is just what we're doing
and
she's eight so
dom's delayed onset muscle soreness is
new to her so when you when you're new
to doms you're like i don't like this
feeling like why would i do push-ups or
why would i do a bunch of squats when my
legs are gonna feel like this the next
day it's like it's like you feel like
your body's kind of being destroyed or
whatever
but when you really understand what doms
is you kind of invite it so i understood
the value of dom's early on i think i
was like 10 or 11 years old
from reading about it or just
understanding that like i worked out
yesterday i'm sore because i'm getting
stronger yes so i found out i forget how
i found out this is
you know whatever 1988 or whatever
however older or whatever
but i knew that your muscles were sore
because they were triggered into like
growing back big or whatever so i'm like
oh shoot so if i do a bunch of push-ups
and i'm not sore i'm like dang i didn't
do enough push-ups or if i ran a bun
like when i started when you you know
the first two days of football practice
you get sore like you're sore your legs
are sore your abs are sore from doing
sit-ups your necks are all this stuff
but i knew that no that's because
they're about to grow back bigger you
kind of invite it so now as an adult i
understand hey man that dom's life is
part of the part of the game man yeah
same thing but you can mitigate it you
can mitigate it not by working out less
or working out weaker oh no but by by
eating the correct foods yeah you're
facilitating the whole dom's process
right there so all that stuff
plus
you can get the drinks at wawa which by
the way we're kind of dominating at wawa
if you go out and you buy stuff from
wawa i am personally thanking you at
this time for making us dominate wawa
don't let up clear shelves go in there
get after it
we're working with a bunch of other
companies we are
i gotta put together a list of where you
can buy
jocko fuel
but right now i can tell you you can get
it at wawa the drinks and you can get it
at the vitamin shop
so or you can get it at joggerfield.com
you ever drink kombucha
i don't like it
me neither and that's kind of the thing
where i'm sorry you know like um drinks
kombucha all the females in my family
yeah they're not drinking that stuff
like
it's methamphetamine or something
to each their own not like they're into
methamphetamine but like it's a very
addictive like something that they're
enjoying you hear good things yeah okay
anyways let me retract that my wife and
daughters like kombucha for whatever
reason yes i think it tastes like crap
like crap yes sir and i'm not even again
my father-in-law he makes his own
kombucha oh so it's like dang okay
obviously grape for you good enough for
you there was a dude that made kombucha
with chocolate white tea by the way no
okay he was selling it combat kombucha i
don't know what happened to it he went
out there's making combat kombu kombucha
kombucha kombucha
kombucha
either way the point okay do you have
any vegetables that you just like you
know okay they're good for you but
problems i'm not gonna eat that because
no i'm just not into it into the taste
or whatever just not like um
asparagus you know people like asparagus
you salted up nice
i think it tastes kind of junk
so i'm not gonna be excited for
asparagus okay
so the good thing and this is why i
think a lot most people
like this energy drink because when you
drink it and you have no guilt you know
that it's actually good freeze it's not
like asparagus is insane well asparagus
is good for you but it tastes bad yes
discipline go is good for you and it
tastes and it tastes good double bonus
exactly right and that's why i think
people like it especially the mango one
by the way i heard great things about
the mango mmm check uh if you want to
get some stuff from this podcast and
represent you can do that too echo made
a store
it's called jacques store yeah 100
uh get some of that stuff
shirt locker so there is a shirt coming
out that i created
mentally and then you have brought to
fruition i think it's gonna be a classic
yeah i think it's gonna be a classic
it's a good one and that one is the
march
march shirt okay
and it's pretty squared away the shirt
locker is the membership did you make
the adjustments you needed to make to
that shirt as
directed no time no time didn't have
time it was already hey what do you call
the ships
[Music]
overcome by events
yeah well look we're good the spelling's
good and that shirt is legit yeah
it looks good that's the marked shirt
yeah and the whole shirt locker is
squared away anyway so it's like if you
order it on march 1st 2nd or what it's
all like up to date yeah see i'm saying
you're good yeah you'd be good to go
check uh so check out jacquardstore.com
subscribe to the podcast jocko
underground
jockowunderground.com who knows i know
we mentioned covid during this
particular
podcast
that's the kind of thing that apparently
gets people banned
gets people uh
in trouble that's why we have
jockwinderground.com
it's 8 and 18 cents a month it allows us
to have a separate platform that we
actually have control over we can say
whatever we want we won't be censored
so if you want to help out there you can
do that if you can't afford it we still
want you in the game just email jocko
underground
assistance at jockowunderground.com
check out the youtube channels
check out the the jocko podcast youtube
channel if you want to see what tony
looks like also origin usa has if you
want to find out what's going on i talk
about these factories and all this stuff
going on check out the origin usa
youtube channel that's got a bunch of
good information on it too
um it's true it's like a psychological
warfare yep get that if you need a
little little hitter yeah anyway i would
say motivation it's not motivating
basically you want jacqueline to help
you pass your moment of weakness so i've
always said it this i'm going to keep
saying it because it's absolutely true
and if you want dakota meyer to help you
pass your moment of meat weakness he's
making cool stuff flipsidecanvas.com
uh
written a bunch of books
if you want to check them out check them
out just go to check out books by jocko
willink you'll find them
some of them are pretty popular
some of them you might like you might be
able to learn something from them
might be able to contact me and tell me
i got something wrong i'm standing by
for adjustment ashland front leadership
consultancy we've got live events that
we do
the next big one we've got is in dallas
texas march 24th and 25th
so if you want to come
to a live event you can go to that we
also have the battlefield events coming
up in gettysburg in may 10th and 12th
and then
gettysburg may 13th and 14th and we're
doing little bighorn as well anyways go
for any of this stuff or you want us to
come and help your company
go to echelonfront.com and check that
out we also have an online training an
online training platform
that's an extra it's at extreme
ownership.com
if you if you have questions for me you
can just go there and ask me a question
i'll be on there yeah i'll be on there
on the zoom meeting remember what zoom
is
covid brought us zoom
one of the good things about covet right
covet brought us zoom now we can
everyone uses zoom now i used to try and
do zoom meetings back in the day or
skype right skype and people just
weren't ready for it now everybody's
like oh zoom call yep we're we're ready
yeah and people understand the benefits
of it yeah so
if you want to talk to me on a zoom call
i will literally be right there go to
extreme extremeownership.com
you can take a bunch of courses we made
we make fresh courses coming out once a
week
leadership
for you not just for like oh you're the
ceo of a company or you're the manager
of this
but if you're leading a family if you're
leading your friends if you're leading
yourself go to extremeownership.com
also if you want to help service members
you can go to mark lee's mom she's got
an awesome charity that she put together
helps out veterans so much go to
americasmightywarriors.org for that and
also check out
heroes and horses which is a
outstanding charity run by micah fink
up there montana getting it and if you
want to support
tony cowden go to like like he said
earlier go to tony cowden.com
and he's also on instagram which is
sounds like that's his primary mode of
communication with the crew
it's
tony underscore cowden underscore
four
the number four and then
nc for north carolina
he's also on twitter tony cowden nc and
facebook youtube tony galden as far as
echo and i go we're both on twitter
we're we're both on the gram we're both
on the facebook
echo echo charles i'm at jacqueline of
course be advised
come to check it out real quick also you
get sucked in by the algorithm don't let
that happen
that's the devil's play thing right
there the algorithm and watch out for
that one
thanks once again for tony to tony for
coming on tonight
thanks for everything that he's done you
know we barely even you you can't spend
what is it eight or nine years in
afghanistan iraq and syria the amount of
stuff that that he's been through that
he's done the amount of risk he's taken
to serve our country you're not going to
cover it in a four-hour podcast or a
20-hour podcast or 100 hour podcast
but that's the kind of person that's
been out there laying his life on the
line for the country now he's stepping
up again
so support him if you can
and thanks for coming tony
and the rest of our
american military out there
and the veterans
thank you all for what you've done
and continue to do to serve our great
nation and to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics emts
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol secret service all first
responders
thank you for keeping us safe on the
home front
[Music]
and to everyone else
how much can you do
i actually know the answer that question
more
that's how much you can do you can do
and a guy like tony makes that obvious
but
it isn't going to knock on your door
you have to kick that door in
you have to make things happen
you have to initiate action
and you do that by going out there
every day
and getting after it
until next time this is echo and jocko